Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt Chaosradio.
Question authority.
Think for yourself.
Throughout human history, as our species has faced the frightening, terrorizing fact that we do not know who we are or where we're going in this ocean of chaos, it has been the authorities, the political, the religious, the educational authorities who attempted to comfort us by giving us a better life.
Wir haben heute eine Sendung, können wir mal den neuen nehmen, anstatt dem klassischen Chaosradio Jingle, den einige vielleicht vermissen werden, aber ich dachte der passt ganz gut. War der gute, also Tim of the Leary. Das Ding stammt von der Live-CD von Thule, aber das hat sich dann auch schon mit der Musik, ihr seid im Chaosradio gelandet, der Sendung mit dem Chaos Computer Club und von denen begrüße ich heute Constanze und den Frank.
Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Eigentlich wollten wir heute über den E-Pass reden und über die biometrische Vollerfassung. Der wichtige Wort ist eigentlich.
Ja, wir müssen also eigentlich die Sendung zweitels mal verschieben. Wir haben ja schon letztes Mal aufgrund der aktuellen Ereignisse die Computer-Wanze, also die Online-Durchsuchung vorgezogen und heute haben wir auch ein sehr brisantes aktuelle Thema, weswegen wir die E-Pass-Sendung jetzt leider gänzlich streichen müssen, aber wir wollen doch trotzdem unsere Hörer darauf hinweisen, weil es uns besonders wichtig ist, dass ab 1. November die Fingerabdrücke in den biometrischen Reisepass kommen. Das heißt, wir fordern explizit alle Leute auf, die wissen, dass sie bald einen neuen Reisepass brauchen, dass sie sich bis Mitte Oktober diesen neuen Reisepass beantragen, damit sie eben keine Fingerabdrücke auf dem Melderemptern abgeben müssen.
Mehr zur Geschichte biometrische Vollerfassung und Reisepass gibt es dann am Samstag in der Sendung Trackback auf Ritz. Die läuft von 18 bis 20 Uhr.
Genau, da haben wir also Frank Rottengaard vom Chaos Computer Club, der da auch noch ein paar Fragen zu beantwortet. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine aktuelle Debatte, weil ja auch wieder der Personalausweis mit biometrischen Merkmalen auf der Tagesordnung steht, politisch jetzt. Aber wir fanden das Thema heute doch so wichtig, dass wir zwar unsere Kampagne starten, nämlich die Kampagne Ich bin doch kein Krimineller, wegen der erkennungsdienstlichen Erfassung auf den Melderemptern, aber dass wir doch diese wichtigen Themen, was wir heute haben, vorziehen. Denn wir werden heute mal eigentlich einen betroffenen Fall vorstellen. Wir haben ja seit Jahren jetzt darüber gesprochen, wie eigentlich Überwachung ablaufen kann, welche Gesetze wir in der letzten Zeit bekommen haben. Aber jetzt wollen wir es mal konkret machen.
Genau, wir reden nämlich im Chaos Radio unter anderem, und auch der Chaos Computer Club sowieso, seit Monaten, Wochen und Jahren über Datensammler, über Datenschutz, über den Missbrauch von Daten und irgendwo Daten angesammelt werden, dass sich Leute natürlich dafür interessieren. Das geht von Paybackkarten bis hin zu euren Online- und euren Handyverbindungen. Es gab ja am Wochenende auch eine große Demonstration in Berlin, die sich gegen diese Datensammelwut richtet. Und alles das, was in den letzten Sendungen zum Thema immer wieder aufkam, war die grundsätzliche Frage, naja, aber ich bin doch ein harmloser Mensch. Mir kann sowas ja eigentlich nicht passieren. Und wir bzw. ihr habt heute einen Gast mitgebracht, der genauer sowas gesagt hat. Mir kann sowas eigentlich nicht passieren. Und dann standen sie bei ihm vor der Tür. Guten Abend, Martin.
Der Grund, warum wir die Sendung geändert haben, ist, weil uns doch sehr diese Frage, ja, eigentlich ist es ja nur theoretisch diese ganzen Sicherheitsgesetze, diese Terrorismus-Vorwurfsdebatten, diese Problematik, dass der Herr Minister Schäuble immer neue Befugnisse für die Sicherheitsbehörden will. Eigentlich erscheinen sie immer so ein bisschen theoretisch so, er will doch eigentlich nur die bösen Terroristen jagen, denkt man doch immer. Und nun ergab es sich, dass in unserer weiteren Bekanntschaft plötzlich jemand war, der nun ein böser Terrorist sein sollte und bei dem sie dann vor der Tür standen. Deswegen haben wir heute den Martin hier, der genau dieses Problem hatte, Sönke Hilbrans, einen Rechtsanwalt, der sich mit den ganzen Themen dieser TKÜV und so weiter und so fort sehr gut auskennt.
Denen ihr natürlich selbstverständlich auch befragen könnt, wenn ihr rechtliche Fragen habt. Sönke, werdet ihr gleich hören, weil so viele Mikrofone haben wir gar nicht. Wir haben hier sehr viele Leute im Studio. Aber selbstverständlich gibt es eine Telefonnummer zu dieser Sendung, die ihr wählen könnt, wenn ihr Fragen habt. Und die heißt 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt es auch online machen, auf fritz.de, im Fritz-Board, beziehungsweise euch direkt beim Chaosradio einklinken in den Stream. So, Frank Schulivertig, musst du das nur ganz kurz anrufen.
Na klar, Telefonnummer muss man haben. Und wir haben noch den Volker Eick hier, ein Politologe, der sich auch mit diesem ganzen Thema Sicherheitsgesetze beschäftigt und sehr gut auskennt.
Also jede Menge Experten, die es zu befragen gilt, wenn ihr da Fragen habt.
Martin, erzähl doch einfach mal, wie fingen das für dich an?
Ja, was ist passiert, Martin?
Ja, es gibt sozusagen zwei Anfänge. Es gab irgendwann mal einen Anfang von einem Ermittlungsverfahren, wo ich gar nichts von mitgekriegt habe. Der eigentliche Anlass für mich war, wo ich gemerkt habe, oh, irgendwas ist komisch. Also ich habe auf Arbeit einen Anruf gekriegt, dass die Polizei in meiner Wohnung steht. Und Hausdurchsuchung angesagt. Ich wusste erst mal gar nicht, was ich da jetzt machen soll. Hab einen Freund angerufen, der meinte, ja, ruf mal einen Rechtsanwalt an. Und der ist dann da erst mal zu meiner Wohnung gegangen. Und dann war ziemlich schnell klar, Vorwurf ist, Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen Vereinigung. Terrorismus, wow, die große Nummer.
War dir klar, dass sie da bei dir an der Tür klingeln werden? Also, Frage andersrum, wenn der Vorwurf steht, Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen Vereinigung, bist du dann in irgendeiner Form aktiv?
Naja, ich bin politisch aktiv in dem, was man so ein bisschen außerparlamentarische Linke nennen würde, mache viel mit Gewerkschaften zusammen, publiziere viel, schreibe Artikel, so ne Sachen. Und natürlich habe ich mich in dem Kontext schon mal damit beschäftigt, was ist irgendwie so ein Terrorismusverfahren, was ist Terrorismus heutzutage. Aber, dass das mich da persönlich treffen wird, absurde Idee.
Also du hast in deinem Keller keine blauen Kanister mit Salpetersäure, wo man...
Nee, nee, da hätte sich das BKA gefreut, glaube ich.
Nur um das kurz klarzustellen, ja. Also du hast einen Anruf bekommen, dass bei dir zu Hause die Polizei steht, um eine Hausdurchsicherung zu machen.
Ja, nee, die steht da nicht. Die war da schon in die Wohnung reingerannt. Also meine Freundin war zu der Zeit noch zu Hause. Und kurz nachdem ich zur Arbeit gegangen war, hat sie da zweimal an der Tür geklopft. Und halbnackt wollte sie die dann aufmachen. Und dann kam mir die Tür schon entgegengeflogen. Zehn Polizisten sind über sie rübergerannt, mit einer Knarre in der Hand, haben da die Wohnung besetzt. Und ja, hartes Programm sozusagen. Also ich hatte in dem Fall dann auch Glück, dass ich nicht zu Hause war. Ja, dann habe ich mich erstmal mit meinem Anwalt verständigt. Der hat da so ein bisschen rumtelefoniert mit der Bundesanwaltschaft. Und dann hieß es relativ schnell, naja, gegen mich konkret liegt jetzt gar nichts Richtiges vor. So persönlichen Bedarf gibt es da gar nicht. Ich kann einfach mal Leben weiterleben. Und ja, dann bin ich erstmal nach Hause gegangen, irgendwann abends wieder aufräumen. Oder es versuchen aufzuräumen.
Wie sah es bei dir zu Hause da aus?
Na, das war schon relativ ordentlich. Ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass das Bundeskriminalamt, was da im Einsatz ist, eher ordentlich arbeitet. Wischen die Staub? Ne, das tun sie nicht. Aber die haben da tatsächlich sämtliche Papiere einmal in die Hand genommen. Also da stehen so 300 Bücher in meiner Wohnung, 400 Bücher vielleicht. Die haben sie alle durchgeblättert, alle persönlichen Notizen mitgenommen, alle Tagebücher. Und natürlich, ganz wichtig, wichtig, alle Datenträger. Ja, also von VHS-Kassetten über USB-Sticks, DVDs, alles. Wo sie irgendwie dachten, da kann man vielleicht elektronische Daten drauf speichern.
Gab es in irgendeiner Form einen Hausdurchsuchbefehl oder eine Erklärung, warum diese Maßnahme stattgefunden hat?
Na die Erklärung lautete ja wohl einfach nur Gefahr im Verzug. Und ein Durchsuchungsbeschluss wurde dann irgendwie Wochen später nachgeliefert. Nö, die kamen erstmal ohne genauere Begründung.
Und im Nachhinein hast du ja dann sicherlich erfahren, was jetzt irgendwie der Anlass war. Wie kamen die darauf, dass du jetzt so ein böser Junge sein solltest?
Ja, die Anwälte haben dann irgendwann natürlich eine Akteneinsicht bekommen. Und aus der geht hervor, dass ein Freund und Kollege von mir eigentlich in ihr Visier geraten ist, weil er einfach genau wie wir alle Texte publiziert hat. Und das BKA hat dann offensichtlich mit einer Internetrecherche festgestellt, dass eine Publikation von ihm neun übereinstimmende Wörter aufweist mit einem Text von einer Militantengruppe. Und haben sich gedacht, das müssen sie mal genauer untersuchen. Und daraufhin haben sie sich dann mit öffentlich zugänglichen Informationen, also alles noch Internet, seine Freunde und Kollegen angeguckt. Und dadurch bin ich dann da reingekommen, weil ich eben zu diesen gehöre und wir mal zusammen in der Redaktion gearbeitet haben.
Das heißt, du hast, da wir heute darüber reden, irgendwie Online-Durchsuchung und so weiter und so fort, bei dir wurde eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt. Es gab nicht wirklich eine Erklärung, warum sie das gemacht haben. Und die einzige Erklärung, die es gibt, dass du sozusagen im großen sozialen Umfeld von Leuten bist, die auch unter Beobachtung stehen, sage ich jetzt mal ganz landläufig. In diesem Scan-Verfahren warst du dann auch mit bei. Jetzt kommt gleich noch Volker, der Politologe, der auch gleich noch was dazu sagen will. Man muss sich irgendwie klar machen, wie absurd die ganze Konstruktion ist. Offensichtlich wollen Bundesanwaltschaft und BKA wissen, wer diese Gruppe ist, haben keinen Plan, setzen sich ans Internet, finden neun übereinstimmende Wörter von einem Text, der fast zehn Jahre alt ist, vergleichen das mit einem Text, der auch schon drei Jahre alt ist. Und auf der Grundlage gucken sie sich dann zunächst mal nur diesen Mann, an der diesen Text geschrieben hat 1998, wo es vergleichbare Wörter drin gibt, und fangen dann an, anzugucken, wer seine Leute sind, mit denen er was zusammen macht. Und Martin ist einer von denen.
Und die haben noch da so Linguistische Tools, so Texto, und wie sie alle heißen, um solche Textvergleichsanalysen durchzuführen. Wurde das denn verwendet, wisst ihr das?
Nee, haben sie bisher, nachdem man weiß ja immer nur, was man aus den Akten weiß. Und danach haben die gewürfelt, würde ich mal sagen, von der Qualität her.
Also es gab da kein Gutachten oder irgendwie sowas in der großen Klasse?
Es gab, gibt natürlich ein Gutachten, aber wenn man weiß, dass das BKA eigentlich, wenn auch allgemein in der Sozialwissenschaft, zumindest als lächerlich bekannte Sprachgutachten eins heißt Kiste, mit dem sie arbeiten und so weiter, wenn man weiß, dass es das gibt, solche aus deren Perspektive elaborierten Programme haben die da nicht benutzt. Die haben einen Gutachten gemacht.
Also ich würde eigentlich ganz gerne nochmal eine Frage stellen, wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, du hast erzählt, was passiert ist, und du bist dann ja quasi wieder in deine Wohnung zurückgekommen. Was ist eigentlich danach gewesen? Wie haben die Leute, mit denen du arbeitest oder die mit dir wohnen, oder deine Familie, wie haben die später reagiert eigentlich?
Ja, es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Also ich habe erstmal ein bisschen Zeit gebraucht, um da ein paar Leute noch drüber zu reden. Ist natürlich erstmal der große Schock. Klar, Terrorismus klingt irgendwie tierisch gewaltig. Und es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Leute. Also die Reaktionen sind ganz unterschiedlich. Ein paar Leute gehen damit ganz souverän um und sagen, okay, hat uns erklärt, wie das ist. Leben geht normal weiter. Wir versuchen mal weiter Normalität zu spielen. Und andere Leute sind aber schon extrem verunsichert. Weil dieses Ermittlungsverfahren läuft jetzt seit einem Jahr, wie wir da aus den Akten erfahren haben. Das heißt ein Jahr praktisch total Überwachung.
Was heißt das genau?
Naja, das heißt auf jeden Fall, dass meine Freunde, Freunde und Kollegen, natürlich auch die Familie wissen, dass unsere Telefonate abgehört werden. Und wenn man das weiß, redet man einfach anders am Telefon. Und dann gibt es Leute, die versuchen, da unbefangen zu wirken. Es gibt Leute, die da ziemlich drucksig werden. Und vielleicht gibt es auch Leute, die gar nicht mehr anrufen. Das ist schon klar.
Was außer dem Telefonüberwachung, wurden an technischen Überwachungsmaßnahmen sozusagen noch in dem gesamten Komplex gefahren?
Man kann glaube ich sagen, das volle Programm. Also von Videoüberwachung der Wohnung, Personenobservation durch BKA-Beamte, der gesamte E-Mail-Verkehr, jeder Brief, jede Postkarte, jedes Päckchen, Telefon, Bahnfahrten, Flüge, alles.
Also das heißt, die haben tatsächlich auch überwacht, wohin sich die Autos der Verdächtigen da bewegen?
Das geht so weit, dass die notiert haben, wer wann mit wem ins Bett geht und ob sie bei Licht oder im dunklen Vögeln.
Wir haben ja den absolut geschützten Kernbereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung geteilt. Es gibt ja Bereiche in jedem Menschenleben, die nicht überwacht werden dürfen, die in diesem Kernbereich liegen. Da können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal Sönke fragen als Anwalt. Wie ist es denn mit diesem Kernbereich? Und ist es in der Praxis tatsächlich so, dass dieser geschützte Bereich geschützt bleibt und nicht überwacht wird?
Der Kernbereich ist eine relativ neue Erfindung der Rechtsprechung, allerdings eine gute Erfindung, sodass man erst seit ein, zwei, drei Jahren überhaupt beobachten kann, was passiert in der Praxis damit. Das, was der Volker beschreibt, ist eine ganz eklatante Verletzung des Kernbereichs, privater Lebensgestaltung schon allein, das Polizei zur Kenntnis nimmt, dass überhaupt, da sich ein Pärchen ins Bett begibt, es schon zu viel des Schlechten an Überwachung. Wir werden erst mal abwarten müssen, was die Rechtsprechung mit dem Kernbereich im Übrigen noch tut. Das ist hoch umstritten. Da wird man sich auch in der Zukunft noch in vielen ganz einzelnen Verfahren und Prozessen drum streiten müssen. Was hat das eigentlich für Konsequenzen? Aber es gibt, das bleibt vielleicht mal zuerst auch festzuhalten, eine ganz klare Aussage dazu vom höchsten Gericht in Deutschland, vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Der Kernbereich privater Lebensgestaltung steht den Ermittlern nicht zur Verfügung. Sie haben sich da herauszuhalten, wenn sie auch nur Gefahr laufen würden, dort einzudringen, dann müssen sie ihre Geräte abschalten, müssen sie die Augen zumachen oder sich vom Hof treuen. Ich habe die Befürchtung, dass diese Information bisher in der Fläche der Strafermittlung noch nicht angekommen ist.
So viel also zu den rechtlichen Grundlagen, worüber wir reden. Ihr seid übrigens im Chaosradio auf Fritz, heute ist er 26. September 2007. Zu Gast ist der Chaos Computer Club, wir haben Teil 128. Und wir reden heute über die Vollüberwachung, die im konkreten Fall von Martin passiert ist, über so Geschichten, dass viele Leute sagen, im Zuge von Bundestrojaner und Onlinedurchsuchungen und so weiter und so fort, dass man Handys tracken kann und Bewegungsprofile von Leuten erstellen kann, über die Mautbrücken und über die Mobilfunkzellen und so weiter und so fort, dass viele Leute sagen, ja aber ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen. Bei Martin war es genauso und plötzlich, es hat er ja gerade erzählt, kriegt er einen Anruf, kommt nach Hause, steht die Polizei nicht, sondern Sbka steht also in voller Montur bei ihm in der Tür und hat eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt, ohne in dem Fall eine konkrete Bestätigung vorzulegen. Und das ist jetzt quasi auch die Frage an euch, beziehungsweise die Aufwand, euch Fragen zu stellen zu diesem Thema. 0331 70 97 110. Es gibt viele, die sagen, na ja, ich habe zu Hause einen Rechner und ja, gut, dann wird irgendwie mal sicher ein bisschen Musik gesaugt und so weiter und so fort. Macht man sich in dem Fall schon verdächtig? Gibt es das Problem, dass man da tiefer ins Visier reinrutscht? Was muss man da befürchten? Und da haben wir heute eine Menge Leute da im Chaosradio, die fragen, wie diese beantworten können.
Ein Aspekt, den wir vielleicht nochmal erklären sollten, dieser Terrorismusverdacht, der begründet sich ja auf diesen Paragraphen 129a der Mitgliedschaftler Gründung einer terroristischen Vereinigung. Vielleicht kannst du das nochmal erklären, was eigentlich dahintersteht und was die Folgen tatsächlich davon sind, wenn man unter Verdacht dieses Paragraphen gerät?
Das sind Fragen, die man, glaube ich, lieber in dem ganzen Buch beantwortet. Also ganz kurz mal runterzubrechen. Paragraph 129a ist, wie einige wenige andere sogenannte Organisationsdelikte im Strafbesetzbuch, kein Delikt, auf den wir jetzt so als Zeitungsleserinnen oder Schülerinnen und Schüler so einfach kommen würden. Das ist eine komplizierte Geschichte. Man muss gar nicht in echte Straftat begehen, also was weiß ich, eine Handtasche klauen oder Raubkopien anfertigen, Drogen handeln oder meinetwegen eine Bombe schmeißen, sondern es reicht, dass man Mitglied einer Organisation ist, deren Zwecke und Tätigkeiten auf bestimmte sehr schwere Straftaten gerichtet sind. Mord und Totschlag oder Entführungen oder aber auch beispielsweise Brandanschläge, wenn diese Straftaten dazu geeignet sind, die Bevölkerung in Angst und Schrecken zu versetzen oder die Regierung und den Staat als Ganzes zu gefährden. Das ist, wie auch der Betroffene gerade schon sagte, die ganz große Keule. 129A hat man nicht für den Vorwurf, bekommt man nicht für überschaubare Straftaten, sondern eher für das ganz große politische Terrorspiel, in das man angeblich verwickelt ist. Die Frage, was macht das mit den Einzelnen, was heißt das für die Betroffenen, die ist häufig nie wirklich zu beantworten. Ganz einfach, weil viele dieser Ermittlungen geheim sind, geheim bleiben und auch immer geheim bleiben werden. Die allerwenigsten Strafverfahren, die Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaften führen, nach § 129a, haben in den letzten 30 Jahren zu Anklageschriften geführt und dazu, dass die ganzen Vorgänge öffentlich vor Gericht verhandelt worden wären. Die allermeisten dieser Verfahren versiegen im Sande. Das heißt aber auch, dass alle Betroffenen, die an zum Beispiel Telefone abgehört wurden, deren zum Beispiel heimlich die Post geöffnet wurde, wo es Lauschangriff gegeben hat oder weiß der Dinge, was noch alles, die werden davon nie etwas erfahren, die wissen dann gar nichts von. Wenn man wie unser Betroffener hier heute in der Sendung dann doch, ich muss fast eher sagen, das Pech, denn das Glück hat, davon etwas mitzubekommen, nämlich dann auch richtig offen durchsucht zu werden, dann kann das, das hat er ja selber auch schon angedeutet, den Schock auslösen. Wir kennen das auch aus anderen Ermittlungen, die sich nicht unbedingt gegen Terrorverdichtige richten müssen. Das bedeutet, die Leute wissen plötzlich, dass ihr Privatleben über Monate, in manchen Fällen über Jahre zuweilen, über viele Jahre ganz intensiv ausgeforscht worden ist. Da wurden möglicherweise doch alle Telefonate abgehört. Das muss man sich erst mal vorstellen. Es wurden vielleicht alle Briefe geöffnet über zig Jahre. Es wurde observiert, die Leute müssen damit leben, dass die Polizei genau weiß, welche Freundinnen und Freunde sie haben. Vielleicht auch das, was ihre Partnerinnen und Partner nicht über sie wissen. Das ist die ganz große Katastrophe in der Privatsphäre. Damit muss man erst mal fertig werden. Und es gibt sehr viele Menschen, ob das so ein Terrorverfahren sind oder irgendwelche anderen Verfahren, die wissen oder auch nur fürchten, sie waren von solchen Ermittlungen betroffen und die nachts ganz schlecht schlafen können.
Es gibt ja in dem Zusammenhang auch immer wieder die Diskussion darüber, wie viel Privatsphäre man von sich selber auch freiwillig preisgibt. Das geht von Kundenkarten bei Tankstellen und bei Kaufhäusern los. Das geht über MySpace-Profile, über Studio-VZ-Profile, wo ich einfach irgendjemand anklicken kann und sofort weiß, was sind deine Freunde, welche Bücher liest du gerne, was hörst du für Musik, wo gehst du heute Abend hin und sonst was. Man denkt, es ist eigentlich nur für den privaten Kreis, aber da kommt ja irgendwie auch jeder ran. Und damit sind wir natürlich wieder bei Datenschutz, bei dem eigentlichen Lieblingsthema von Chaos Computer Club. Und bei Fragen, die ihr habt unter 0331 77 97 110 angerufen hat, Rainer aus Berlin. Guten Abend, Rainer. Grüß dich. Wir haben heute viele Experten im Studio und das ist ein weites Feld. Wozu willst du eine Frage stellen?
Ja, mehrere Fragen. Aktuell eben durch den Fortfach in den letzten Minuten, wenn jemand überwacht wird und das kommt raus, psychischen Schäden sind ja angesprochen worden, kriegt der eine Art Schmerzensgeld, wenn nachher sein Verfahren gegen ihn im Sand verläuft, zum Beispiel oder generell?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Vielleicht kann Sönke was dazu sagen. Der ist ja Anwalt und kennt sich mit diesen Dingen ganz gut aus.
Ja, automatisch kriegt er leider kein Menschenschmerzensgeld für. Man kann den Versuch starten, das in langen Jahren vor Gericht durchzusetzen. Das ist in ganz wenigen Fällen auch passiert. Aber man muss vielleicht bedenken, die Leute, die irgendwann rausfinden, dass sie so in der Privatsphäre kaputt gemacht worden sind, dass sie so ausgeforscht worden sind, die müssen erst mal mit dem Schock fertig werden. Und dann auch noch die Nerven zu haben und auch die Monäten zusammen zu kratzen, das Ganze dann vor die Justiz zu treiben, das ist eine Hammerart der Aufgabe. Es stellen sich bisher nur wenige, es gibt also nur wenig Vorbilder in der Rechtsprechung, aber es hat auch schon geklappt.
Also ein eindeutiges Vielleicht?
Leider ein eindeutiges Vielleicht. Als Anwalt würde ich sagen, klar, muss man darüber nachdenken, muss man es versuchen, aber bitte, das heißt, die nächsten fünf oder zehn oder noch mehr Jahre muss man sich immer noch damit beschäftigen. Das ist für die Einzelnen hart zu verpacken.
Die Datenträger, die beschlagnahm worden sind, hat er die wiedergekriegt alle? Oder sind da auch noch mal bei der Haftung, wenn da welche kaputtgegangen sind, das Material bezahlt, wenn da was kaputt geht, ein Computer oder eine Fissplatte?
Ja, also ich habe über meinen Anwalt dann erwirkt, dass ich zumindest meinen Computer, den ich einfach zum Arbeiten brauche, weil ich ja publiziere, relativ schnell wiederkriege. Aber alles andere ist einfach mal weg. Also das bleibt dann irgendwo. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe da irgendwas von Meckenheim gehört, das wahrscheinlich Monate lang liegen.
Das heißt, es fehlt auch ein Archiv und Arbeitsmaterial.
Ja, das ist alles weg. Das ist viel härter. Das ist ja noch so bei Notizen und Tagebüchern, wo sozusagen die ganzen Adressen drin stehen und Kontakte und so was. Die sind auch alle weg.
Gut, jetzt aktuell noch mal zur Technik. Ab nächstes Jahr ist ja die Telefonverbindungsvorratsdatenhaltung angesagt. Mir passt das also persönlich auch nicht. Und das ist mir also ein bisschen ausufernde Einschränkung der persönlichen Freiheit. So, da macht man sich natürlich die Gedanken, was kann man da machen. Also die Frage ist folgende. Ich kann mir für wenig Geld einen virtuellen Server irgendwo mieten und könnte da zum Beispiel eine, oder Linux, eine Asterik, also eine Telefonanlage oder Telefonsoftware draufpacken. Und das so als man in the middle verwenden. Die Frage ist, wenn ich da jetzt ein oder mehrere Zwischenstellen drüber durchschalte, wird der Verbindungsteilnehmer, also der reale Mensch, der dann nachher mit mir spricht, auch erfasst oder nur die erste Telefonnummer oder ersten Anlauf, mit dem ich mich selber verbinden lasse?
Warte mal Rainer, ich bin ja eine Technik 5. Ob ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, mal gucken, weil ich versuche es nochmal mit anderen Worten zu sagen. Also man hat nicht ein Telefonat zwischen dir und mir, sondern zwischen dir und mir stehen sozusagen noch drei weitere Schaltzellen, über die dieses Telefongespräch läuft. Und du willst jetzt wissen, ob sozusagen nur von dir zum ersten Punkt das geht, oder ob man auch über diese drei Ecken nachverfolgen kann. Habe ich richtig verstanden? Gut, dann ist jetzt Frank dran, weil ich glaube, der hat darauf die Antwort.
Also die A ist nicht so ganz einfach, weil du brauchst halt mehrere Asterisk-Server, die...
Wie heißt die Asterisk?
Asterisk ist diese Telefonanlagen-Software, die auf dem PC laufen kann. Und du musst halt sicherstellen, dass dein Gespräch halt da durchgerutet wird. Und du musst sicherstellen, dass mindestens einer dieser Server außerhalb der deutschen bzw. europäischen Juristikation steht. Das heißt also, dass sie nicht diese Geräte einfach schlicht auch von der Vorratsdatenspreichung in einem anderen Land betroffen werden. Weil natürlich kann man mit entsprechenden Abfragen in diese Vorratsdaten auch konstruieren, wer sich über welchen Rechner zu wem anders verbindet. Abgesehen davon ist es leider einigermaßen unpraktikabel, weil du musst halt irgendwie dann ein ziemlich aufwendiges Routing-Verfahren machen, um sicherzustellen, dass die Leute dich erreichen können.
Also du musst bedenken, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung keine deutsche Angelegenheit ist, sondern ja Gesamteuropa betrifft also eine halbe Milliarde Menschen und du müsstest dich also schon mit deinem Master's aus Europa wegbewegen.
Die Frage, in welches Land ist es denn im Moment noch nicht angesagt?
Tja, das fragen wir uns auch gerade. Also die Idee ist prinzipiell gut, aber die technische Umsetzung ist halt leider weniger trivial als gedacht.
Rainer, ich glaube jetzt wären wir extremstechnisch. Die Antwort auf die Frage, welche ich richtig verstanden habe, ist, es ist ziemlich kompliziert im Moment und ich möchte an der Stelle auch darauf hinweisen, dass wir nicht alle tiefgreifenden technischen Probleme in dieser doch relativ kurzen Sendung klären können. Das heißt, wenn du da noch spezifische Anfragen oder sonstige Dinge hast, die mit, was weiß ich hier, Ping 385 Parameter QX ändern, dann mail doch einfach dem Chaos Computer Club unter chaosradio.ccc.de und da könnt ihr dann untereinander 19 Zoll Gespräche führen.
Entschuldige bitte, das geht nicht zu sehr ins Detail. Da ich verbute mal, dass die größte Anzahl eurer Leute alleine schon von eurem Titel hier in der Informatik bewandert ist, dürfte die größte Mehrheit eurer Hörer, die aus dem Informatikbereich kommen, deshalb bin ich auch bei euch am Telefon und in der Leitung. In Anführungsstrichen, die Teilwissen haben mit dem Standort.
Na ja, Reiner, Moment, wir senden ja nicht nur für Informatiker und für Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, sondern wir reden ja heute hauptsächlich über Datenschutz und über Datensammeln. Deswegen führt also wirklich dieses Technikproblem in dieser Sendung jetzt eindeutig zu weit. Also ich bitte dich, das zu respektieren und wenn ihr da noch Sachen erklären wollt, dann macht das.
Dann werde ich mich bemühen, es ist noch eine Frage, die auch die Technik betrifft, um zu beteiligen. Also wir haben ja einen Hersteller, der hier in Berlin beheimatet ist, der am Markt einen sehr großen Marktanteil mit seinem ADSL Modems und Rudern hat. So, nachdem ich mich bei Google mit dem Schlagwort, mit dem Namen dieses technischen Gerätes durch 30 bis 50 Seiten gehangelt habe, war irgendwie, habe ich in Erinnerung, ein Hinweis, dass es möglich sein soll, mit einer Diagnose Softwarefunktion der Firmware sich von außen in das Gerät einhaken zu können und da Manipulation vornehmen zu können. Die Frage ist, ist das bei allen Geräten so? War das jetzt nur bei diesem besonderen Hersteller? Beziehungsweise, was kann ich dagegen tun?
Können die dazu was sagen?
Nicht wirklich. Also diese Plastikisten sind halt irgendwie alle mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt. Und wer nicht zu Ende getestet heißt, also die haben eigentlich alle Löcher. Wenn du irgendwie sicher gehen willst, dann bau dir einen eigenen Router, nennst du dir dein eigenes Linux da drauf und benutze halt irgendwie keine Komponenten, wo du halt nicht reingucken kannst.
Schönen Abend noch nach Berlin. 0331-70-97-110, Chaosradio Teil 128. Wir haben jetzt gleich die Nachrichten und wollen dann auch gerne weiter mit euch drüber diskutieren über Datensammelwut und über Schutz der Privatsphäre und alle diese Geschichten, die wir auch in den letzten Sendungen immer wieder besprochen haben. Unter dem Aspekt, mir kann sowas doch eigentlich nicht passieren. Bei uns ist Martin, dem ist genau sowas passiert. Und wenn ihr da konkrete Fragen habt, könnt ihr die gerne hier stellen an fritz-0331-70-97-110.
Wir haben 37, 4 Prozent unserer Hörer gefragt, was sie denn am liebsten machen. Drinnen tanzen.
Draußen chillen.
Drinnen tanzen.
Fritz-Doc-Disco. Drinnen tanzen.
Draußen chillen.
Die Fritz-Club-Disco. Jetzt wieder mit Sommergarten. Immer samstags ab 23 Uhr im Fritz-Club im Postbahnhof. Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Es ist halb elf.
Die Lage bei den Massenprotesten in Birma ist heute eskaliert. Die Militärregierung ging mit Gewalt gegen die Demonstranten vor. Mindestens acht Menschen, darunter fünf Mönche, sollen von Sicherheitskräften erschossen worden sein. Immer mehr Politiker weltweit fordern jetzt schärfere Sanktionen gegen das Land. Der Welt-Sicherheitsrat befasst sich aktuell auf einer Sondersitzung mit der Lage in Birma. Der Bundesgerichtshof hat ein Grundsatzurteil zum Unterhalt nach Scheidungen getroffen. Die Richter kamen zu dem Schluss, dass der Besserverdienende nicht lebenslang Unterhalt an den früheren Partner zahlen muss. Mit dieser Entscheidung werden zeitlich befristete Zahlungen erlaubt. Aber der wirtschaftlich schlechter gestellte soll sich langfristig mit dem begnügen, was er selbst erwirtschafte. Eine Ausnahme seien nur Frauen, die wegen der Kindererziehung, in der Ehe auf ihren Beruf verzichtet haben. Deutschland hinkt in Sachen Korruptionsbekämpfung hinterher. Laut einer Studie der Organisation Transparency International liegt Deutschland im europäischen Vergleich nur auf Platz 16. Experten äußerten, dass hierzulande erst seit kurzem etwas gegen Korruption getan wird. Im weltweiten Vergleich hingen Somalia und Burma, die am schlechtesten schneiden, und Dänemark und Finnland und Neuseeland am besten. Zum Sport. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen steht im WM-Finale. Die Titelverteidigerinnen gewannen das Halbfinale gegen Norwegen mit 3 zu 0. Und in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Energie Cottbus eine Niederlage einstecken müssen. Der Tabellenletzte verlor auswärts gegen den Tabellenersten Bayern München mit 0 zu 5. Die weiteren Ergebnisse, Nürnberg gegen Leverkusen 1 zu 2, Stuttgart gegen Bochum 1 zu 0, Frankfurt Karlsruhe 0 zu 1 und Bielefeld gegen Hannover 0 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, Angermünde und Wittenberge 10 Grad, Potsdam 11 Grad, Frankfurt 12 Grad und Cottbus und Neuropin 13 Grad und in Berlin auch 13 Grad. In der Nacht ist es meist wolkig, im Süden Brandenburgs kann es etwas regnen. Es kühlt ab auf 10 bis 8 Grad. Morgen soll es meistens wolkig bleiben. Ab und zu kann es regnen bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Verkehr auf den Straßen ist nichts los.
Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Ganz neue Musik auf Fritz, eine neue Band aus Dänemark, aus Aarhus, die heißen Grand Avenue, Platte kommt 1. Oktober. Sie waren gerade beim Popcom Radio zu Gast. Das war das Titelstück vom kommenden Album Outside. Ihr seid auf Fritz im Blue Moon. Heute ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Das heißt, wir haben das Chaosradio, wie immer mit dem Chaos Computer Club heute, Teil 128. Und wir haben heute Unmengen an Studio Gestick. Fangen wir an. Also vom Chaos Computer Club sind da Konstanze und Frank. Hallo. Dann ist bei uns Volker Eick als Politologe. Dann ist bei uns Sönke Hilbrans, er ist Rechtsanwalt. Und dann ist bei uns noch Martin, der gerade seine Geschichte erzählt hat. Es geht um Überwachung durchs BKA. Wir haben ja in den letzten Sendungen viel über Dinge gesprochen wie den Bundestrojaner und über Handy-Tracking und alles solche Geschichten. Viele von euch haben auch in den letzten Sendungen immer wieder gesagt, wenn sie bei mir gucken wollen, sondern sie machen mir das. Sorry, ich habe mir nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen. Und plötzlich stehen sie irgendwann vor der Tür. Martin ist es genauso passiert. Er hat seine Geschichte vorhin erzählt. Wir haben heute, wie gesagt, sehr viele Experten im Studio. Wenn ihr also zu dieser ganzen Thematik Fragen habt, dann könnt ihr die gerne stellen unter 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Lutz. Hallo Lutz.
Ja, hallo, schönen guten Abend. Ja, erst mal Kompliment, dass ich überhaupt den Mut habe, so eine Sendung zu machen. Das wird einigen Leuten garantiert nicht gefallen. Ja, mich würde mal interessieren, ob er weiß, ob er online überwacht worden ist.
Martin?
Ja, also was heißt online überwacht? Es liefen da offensichtlich die Sachen vom Provider weiter. Und dann gibt es in diesen Unterlagen vom Verfahren so Hinweise, welche Homepage ich mir angeguckt habe.
Gibt es da Fragen an euch auch noch mal vom Chaos Computer Club? Das haben wir in den letzten Sendungen immer wieder besprochen. Gibt es für mich als normalen User, der irgendwie seine Mails liest und so weiter und so fort, gibt es da für mich Hinweise, wo ich sagen kann, oh, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, dass der Rechner langsamer läuft oder das Bild ruckelt oder irgend so was? Oder das Kabel komisch aussieht?
Also man muss halt unterscheiden zwischen einer Internetüberwachung, sprich, dass irgendeiner der Bedarfträger oder Sicherheitsbehörden sich anguckt, was man mit seiner Internetleitung macht. Also was da passiert, welche Webseiten man sich ansieht, mit wem man E-Mail-Verkehr hat und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Das findet bereits statt, das findet sehr ausführlich statt. Also wie wir es gerade gehört haben, wahrscheinlich auch in diesem Verfahren. Und was jetzt neu dazu kommt, ist ja diese Diskussion um die Computer-Wanzen oder auch Bundestrojaner, wo es darum geht, dass auf dem Computer selbst eine Überwachung stattfindet, also sprich, die Daten, die auf dem Computer eingegeben werden, die Daten, die auf dem Computer gespeichert sind, online heruntergeladen werden.
Ich muss mal den Hörer fragen, meintest du denn diese so genannte Online-Aussuchung, also die Computer-Wanze?
Ja, ja allgemein mehr, weil gesetzlich gibt es da ja eigentlich noch keine Grundlage für. Und dann geht es ja darum, wie kann man sich rechtlich jetzt dagegen wehren. Das ist natürlich ein Prozedere, aber langsam wird es ja Zeit, dem Staat, dem die immer alles gefallen zu lassen. Denn rausgekommen ist ja, bevor die Diskussion losging um die Online-Überwachung, dass das ja vorher schon gemacht ist. Und das betrifft jetzt auch den Anrufer vorher. Ich gehe grundsätzlich davon aus, dass der Staat alles kann und auch alles macht, ob das legal oder illegal ist. Er macht es. Wenn er heute von Online-Überwachung spricht und das Gesetz durchdrücken will, dann tut er dies bestimmt schon zwei Jahre mit bestimmten Leuten, die richtig interessant sind.
Also was ja bekannt ist, ist, dass diese Computer-Wanzen zumindest im geheimdienstlichen Bereich schon ausführlich eingesetzt werden. Und dass es halt in die vereinzelten Fälle wohl auch gab im Strafverfolgerbereich. Da gibt es diese lustige Geschichte angeblich, dass in Berlin es auch eingesetzt werden worden sein soll. Bis es halt irgendwie dieses Urteil vom Bundesgerichtshof gab, die gesagt haben, nee dafür reicht aber jetzt die gesetzliche Grundlage nicht aus, denkt euch mal was aus. Und was da gerade läuft, ist das Verfahren vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, wo es um den Einsatz in Nordrhein-Westfalen ging, also wo der Verfassungsschutz in Nordrhein-Westfalen diese Computer-Wanzen einsetzen wollte und dagegen geklagt wurde. Und da werden wir sehen, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht dazu meint, ob das verfassungsgemäß ist, so was zu tun oder nicht.
Da habe ich ganz kurz noch eine Frage dazwischen. Stichpunkt Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Bislang, es gibt doch Fristen, wie lange so diese Daten eigentlich aufbewahrt werden und danach sollten sie ja dann irgendwann in den digitalen Schredder laufen. Jetzt habe ich letztens gefährliches Halbwissen. Achtung vorneweg. Jetzt habe ich gehört, dass diese Daten nicht nach sechs Monaten gelöscht werden, sondern dass es durchaus möglich ist, den Online-Verkehr der letzten zehn Jahre problemlos nachzuvollziehen.
Naja, es gibt in Deutschland momentan die Planung, diese Daten für sechs Monate zu halten, also die telekommunikationsverbindungsdaten, also nicht die Inhalte der Gespräche.
Das heißt nur, wen ich wann angemailt habe.
Ja, jawohl. Und dazu zählen auch SMS beispielsweise oder Anrufe, die eben nur versucht wurden und nicht erfolgreich waren. Aber wir haben bereits die Forderung vom Bundesrat, diese Speicherfrist auf ein Jahr zu erhöhen. Und die zugrunde liegende EU-Rechtlinie, die also aus Brüssel kommt, die erlaubt, diese Speicherfrist auch auf zwei Jahre zu erhöhen. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass sie zumindest nicht noch die Speicherfrist verlängern. Die sechs Monate sind schlimm genug.
Lutz ist deine Frage damit beantwortet.
Ja, gut. Kann man natürlich jetzt so, ja, was ich noch fragen wollte, ihr habt ja einen Rechtsanwalt da sitzen. Kann man überhaupt, so wie ich jetzt, so ganz normal auch kritisch durch die Welt gehe und mich für dies oder jenes interessiere, kann man das irgendwo vorher rauskriegen, wie weit man irgendwo schon erfasst wird oder konkret erfasst? Ich kenne das zum Beispiel vom LKW-Fahren. Ich bin von Polen aus reingekommen, da war die Polen nicht in EU. Da haben die meinen Pass durchgezogen, wie sie es immer machen, und die waren netter vom Bundesgrenzschutz. Und ich habe dann gesagt, ich sage, was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich zu sehen? Du kann ich dir zeigen. Ich war natürlich völlig überrascht, was da zu sehen war. Weil ich nun kein unbescholener Bürger bin, auf einer anderen Beziehung.
Was war denn da zu sehen?
Da war alles zu sehen. Da war zu sehen, was ich mal gemacht habe, was abgeurteilt worden ist, was angeblich noch in Ermittlungen ist und was ich eben nicht wusste. Ich hatte ein Häkchen beim BKA in Wiesbaden und ich hatte ein Häkchen beim LKA in Kiel. Warum, ist mir klar, aber ich habe ja gar nicht gewusst, dass da überhaupt jemand an mich interessiert ist in einer bestimmten Hinsicht. Das hat jetzt gar nichts mit Politik oder irgendwas zu tun, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber man weiß es ja gar nicht. Mich würde man interessieren, das ist genau so ein Ding mit Büchern zum Beispiel. Nun bestelle ich gern Bücher oder lese gern Bücher. Allerdings auch solche Bücher, die nicht immer so im Handel so offiziell angepriesen werden, die nicht verboten sind, die stehen nicht auf dem Index. Da ist auch Scholatur mit bei in manchen Katalogen, aber in den USA z.B. werden sämtliche Leute in den Bibliotheken und auch in den Buchhandlungen sofort mit Adresse registriert und weitergegeben die Adresse, die ganz bestimmte Art und Weile und Themen an Büchern bestellen. Wie weit ist das denn hier schon, ob der Rechtsanwalt weiß, oder ob man überhaupt eine Möglichkeit hat mal zu sagen, so ich möchte jetzt gern mal wissen, wie weit man mich irgendwo auf dem Zettel hat.
Okay, also um deine Frage andersrum zu formulieren, kann ich irgendwo nachfragen oder rauskriegen, was über mich gespeichert wird und was über mich alles vorhanden ist. Sönke, kannst du dazu was sagen?
Also dein Instinkt trügt dich nicht und ich finde auch dein Erlebnis an der polnischen Grenze eigentlich ganz instruktiv, weil die Grenze der Sachen über dich rausfinden konnten, einfach mal so online, die sie gar nicht wissen wollten, die sie überhaupt nicht interessiert haben und die sie auch gar nicht wissen mussten. Das ist ja so perfekt, fast schon Globalisierung von Daten, also das finde ich beeindruckend. Ist auch himmelschreiend rechtswidrig, aber technisch ohne Weiteres möglich und offenbar mit dem heutigen Grenzverhandlungsbestand auch Standard. Deine Frage geht dahin, was kannst du eigentlich rausfinden? Natürlich dann in der Folge, wie kann ich mich eigentlich schützen? Vielleicht mal so als Einstieg, also das, was sie gerade laufen von dir wollen, was gerade laufend gegen dich läuft, das wirst du mit ziemlicher Wahrscheinlichkeit erst dann rausfinden, wenn sie vor der Tür stehen oder dir eine Anklageschrift zustellen oder dir vielleicht mal ein Zettel schicken, auf dem drauf steht, sie dürfen sich mal hier zum Interview einfinden, aber das verpflichtet sie zu nichts. Also die Benachrichtigung der Polizei über ein Strafverfahren. Also alles, was gerade so läuft, das würden sie dir nicht mitteilen, wenn sie interessiert daran sind, dass du das nicht erfährst. Das steht auch in jedem Gesetz so, wo es dann eigentlich auch in jedem anderen Sicherheitsparagrafen dann irgendwo eine Fußnote gibt, dass du auch Auskunftsanträge stellen kannst. Das ist ein mühsames Geschäft. Da gibt es übrigens im Internet auch, ich glaube bei Google mit dem Stichwort Auskunftsgenerator zu finden, eine Website, wo du dir sozusagen für die einschlägigen Standardsicherheitsbehörden dein eigenes Auskunftsersuchen generieren kannst. Das sind dann, ich sage mal, die Standardbehörden, die man so anschreibt, wenn man es wissen will, sind die Verfassungsschutzämter des Bundes und der Länder und die Polizeien des Bundes und der Länder, also dann auch das Bundeskriminalamt, eingeschlossen. Du hast als Bürgerin oder Bürger da jederzeit einen Auskunftsanspruch, der ist auch kostenlos. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, das wenigstens kostet dich nur die Briefmarke. Und dann kannst du da hinschreiben, deine Identität klarstellen. In der Regel verlangt man von dir, dass du eine Kopie vom Personalausweis mir schickst, damit auch jeder glaubt, dass du das bist, der da anfragt und nicht irgendjemand anders mal was über dich rausfinden will. Und dann bekommst du Auskunft, zum Beispiel das, was du auch da von den Grenzern erfahren hast, dass du mal in Köln, Quatsch, in Kiel ein Strafverfahren hattest und mal, keine Ahnung, was du irgendwo anders... Also die ganzen unverfänglichen Sachen, die kriegst du darüber raus.
Ja, Strafverfahren war das nicht. Das war eigentlich nur so. Er hat mir gesagt, hier kann ich sehen, das war mal, das ist abgehandelt und und und. Und dann eben war eben zu sehen, dass LKA Kiel irgendwie Interesse an mich hat oder da irgendwie ermittelt oder ich da beobachtet werde oder auf dem Zettel stehe und BKA in Wiesbaden. Wo das herkommt, ist mir klar, weil ich mit bestimmten Leuten Umgang habe.
Na, aber das fühlt jetzt sowieso zu weit, Lutz, glaube ich. Wenn wir die persönliche Geschichte ausdröseln.
Ich wollte auch noch fragen, ob ihr was von diesen... Ich habe im Internet, durch Zufall, ich bin nicht so oft im Internet, schon gar nicht privat mit meinem Gerät, das mache ich grundsätzlich, aber wie der HA, also HAAL oder AAV verfahren irgendwelche neuen Techniken durch Wände durch, Filmen zu können, abhören, bla, bla, bla.
Das ist jetzt was für Technik- oder Science-Fiction-Autoren, ich gebe das mal weiter.
Ja, gut, also kann ich jetzt gar nicht so viel mit anfangen, so.
Ich habe da manchmal reingelesen, das war mir ein bisschen zu viel, so, und zu doll, aber ich habe jetzt nur gedacht, wenn ihr da mal beißt, ob da was dran ist oder nicht.
Pass auf, also wenn der Chaos Computer Club dieser technisch ziemlich fit sind, wenn die jetzt sagen, hm, ist uns jetzt so in der Form auch nicht bekannt, dann würden wir das jetzt im Moment erst mal in die Rubrik Stanislav Lem schieben und hoffen, deine Frage hiermit beantwortet zu haben. Chaos Radio Teil 128 auf Fritz0331, 70 97 110. Ich kann nicht lesen, was du auf deinem Zettel geschrieben hast.
Eine der Fragen, die hier kamen, war, wie ist es dann mit dem Zugriff auf die Daten, die über mich bei privaten Firmen gespeichert sind?
Was heißt private Firmen?
Der Volker erwähnte vorhin, dass es Anfragen bei der Bahn gab. Kannst du ein bisschen was dazu sagen, wie da die Praxis lief, was da tatsächlich gefragt wurde und wer da wie geantwortet hat?
Ich poche eine Bahnfahrkarte online und ob irgendjemand nachvollziehen kann, wann ich wo, mit welcher Bahn, wo, in welchem Falle konkret haltet BKA. Na ja, das fängt an mit dem Grunde nach, nennt sich das Bestandsdaten-Abfrage. Da wird also zunächst mal gefragt, Meldeadresse, zweite Meldeadresse usw. Das sind Anfragen an Behörden. Die Behörden müssen da auch Auskunft geben. Und dann geht das sozusagen Stück für Stück weiter. Dann wird bei der Bahn angerufen bzw. wird in der Regel immer hingefaxt mit der Bitte, um in deren Rechner zu prüfen, wenn man eine Bahncard hat, 25, 50, wie auch immer, wenn man Bonusmeilen hat usw. usf. Wann ist diese Person mit der Bahncard wohin gefahren, wann ist sie wieder zurückgekommen? Ach, das wird ausgelesen, wenn die Bahncard durchgezogen wird. Das ist interessant. Dasselbe Spielchen natürlich auch bei Flügen oder Postbeschlagnahme. Das ganze Programm. Banken sind mittlerweile auch verpflichtet, diese Daten weiterzugeben. Aber nehmen wir mal eine Autovermietung. Das BKA will wissen, wer sich ein Auto gemietet hat. Dann schicken wir eine Fax, ich nenne jetzt keine Firma, irgendeine Autofirma XYZ, und bitten um Auskunft, ob sich folgende Personen, wir haben ja gerade diesen Fall gehabt, diesen Skandal mit 18 Leuten, wo sie eine Faxliste geschickt haben an diese Autovermietung. Hier diese 18 Leute, wollen wir wissen, ob die bei euch Autos gemietet haben, wann, wie lange, wann sie zurückgegeben haben, habt ihr die noch usw. Und dann ist es der Autofirma dem Grunde nach freigestellt. Ach, die müssen gar keine Auskunft geben?
Na ja, sie tun es halt oft. Es gibt ja da die ganz großen Fälle in Deutschland, der sogenannte Mikado-Fall, wo die Ermittlungsbehörden bei allen Kreditkartenfirmen angefragt haben nach einer bestimmten Summe, die transferiert wurde.
Das war der Fall, wo es um die Ermittlung von Kindern und Pornografie ging.
Ja, es ging halt um eine bestimmte Summe, die bezahlt wurde. Sie wollten herausfinden, wer diese Summe bezahlt hat. Sie haben sich an die Kreditkartenfirmen gewandt. Da ist heute noch das Gerichtsverfahren anhängig, ob das legal ist. Auf jeden Fall haben aber die Kreditkartenfirmen die Auskunft erstmals verteilt.
In dem konkreten Fall war es so, dass die BKA alle Autovermietungen pauschal geschrieben hat. Und alle Telefonfirmen und gefragt hat, waren die bei euch aktiv?
Man kann sich das im Prinzip wie ein großes Sponsoringunternehmen für die Telekom vorstellen, weil die die Dinger tatsächlich an jede Autofirma gefaxelt haben.
Das heißt, sie haben da einen Standardverteiler und dann kippen sie da die Namen rein und kriegen dann die Antworten zurück?
Ob sie einen Standardverteiler haben oder ob sich da jemand noch hinsetzen muss, eine Sekretärin oder ein Sekretär, und diese Liste erst noch zusammenstellen, das wissen wir jetzt nicht. Aber dem Grunde nach, erstmal alles raushauen. Und dann hat man eben, das ist jetzt aber mehr so Kontextbahn, da hat man dann auch den zuständigen Sachbearbeiter, der sich auch noch andient und sagt, wenn Sie noch weitere Fragen haben, dann können Sie mich auch gerne nach Dienstschluss anrufen, seine Privatnummer auch noch mit angibt und so weiter. Sofort, wo man sozusagen extra Freiwillige da noch hat in dem Kontext, die noch mehr anbieten, als es eigentlich gefragt worden ist. Und es gibt aber eben auch andere Firmen im Bereich Servern. Da kennt ihr euch ja besser aus, aber im Bereich Server ist das eben so. Manche Serverbetreiber bieten sich auch den BKA an, dienen sich dem quasi an, und andere sagen, ne, Moment mal, warte mal. So geht es aber nicht. Chaosradio 128, wir reden natürlich, wie in vielen anderen Sendungen vorher auch, über Überwachung, was geht in der Praxis schon konkret. Stichwort Online-Durchsuchung, Stichwort Bundestrojaner. Wir können da gerne auch nochmal auf Paybackkarten und diese ganzen schönen Sachen aufmerksam machen, wo man ja wunderbar von sich auch Daten streut und damit auch Benutzerprofile freigibt. Aber vorrangig ist diese Sendung natürlich für euch da, dass ihr Fragen stellen könnt unter 0331 70 97 110, wie z.B. Marek aus Cottbus. Guten Abend, Marek.
Ja, und zwar habe ich vor einigen Wochen ein Laptop bekommen. Aber noch kein Internet. Jetzt wollte ich nur mal wissen, jetzt würde ich mir aber das Internet dazu legen, was ich da beachten muss, was ich überlassen sollte.
Wie was du beachten musst?
Also du meinst, hast du grundsätzlich Angst, diesen Rechner ans Netz zu bringen, weil du dir vielleicht eine Computerwanze einfängst oder jemand deine Daten ausspioniert? Willst du in diese Richtung?
Ja, ich hatte schon mal ein Verfahren am Hals. Und da ging es halt um verbotene Filme. Es ging aber nicht über meinen Computer, sondern Computer vom Freund. Und dadurch ist es halt alles aufgeflogen.
Wie du dein Video, deinen Computer sicher machst. Und wir reden jetzt nicht über Firewall, und wir reden nicht über einen Viren-Scanner und sonstige Geschichten. Hattest du das richtig verstanden? Okay. Also sind wir wieder bei der Frage, die wir vorhin schon mal hatten. Kriege ich irgendwie mit, wenn auf meinem Computer der Bundestrojaner drauf ist, ruckelt das Bild oder was kann ich tun? Im Zweifelsfall kannst du einfach den alten Ratschlag beherzigen, öffne keine Mails, die du nicht kennst, und von Leuten, die du nicht erwartest, machst du bitte die Anhänger auch nicht auf. Das hat ja meine Oma begriffen.
Ja, also de facto ist es so, dass wenn sie hinter dir her sind und es wirklich wollen, kriegst du es wahrscheinlich im Zweifel nicht mit. Wenn du halt Daten verarbeiten möchtest, von denen du nicht möchtest, dass irgendjemand da reinguckt, dann verarbeite sie auf einem Computer, der nicht am Internet hängt. Das ist halt der einfache Ratschlag.
Frage beantwortet? Alles klar, dann danke für den Anruf. 0331 70 97 110. Eure Fragen an den Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio 128. Der nächste am Telefon ist René aus Berlin. Guten Abend, René.
Guten Abend. Grüß dich. Ich habe keine Frage, das kommt erst mal am Ende. Ich wollte erst mal erzählen, was mir so passiert ist. Und zwar habe ich einen Anruf bekommen von einem Freund nach Hause. Der hat mir über einen Überfall erzählt, was er gemacht hat. Ich habe mich angehört und mir nichts dabei gedacht. Tatsächlich kam am nächsten Tag die LKA bei mir vorbei, hat meine ganze Wohnung auseinandergenommen, hat mein Handy genommen und mich festgenommen und in die Uhr aufgesteckt. Und ich wusste erst mal nicht, warum ich überhaupt in der Uhr auf war, was ich überhaupt gemacht habe und so. Ich war auch das erste Mal im Knast, ich wusste nicht, was man da macht, wenn so etwas passiert. Ich habe mir auch keinen Rechtsanwalt geholt oder irgendwas. Sie haben mich gefragt, ob ich einen Rechtsanwalt habe. Ich meinte nein. Und vor dem Haftrichter haben sie mir auch nicht erzählt, was ich gemacht habe, warum ich eigentlich jetzt im Knast komme und so. Und dann irgendwann mal kam, habe ich halt im Knast so ein bisschen rumgefahren und so. Sie meinten, warum ich hier bin, ich meinte, ich weiß nicht. Und dann meinten die am besten, du suchst einen Rechtsanwalt. Dann habe ich zur Sozialarbeiterin gegangen. Ich meinte, ich brauche einen Rechtsanwalt. Dann kam ein Rechtsanwalt hierher und hat Akteneinsicht gefordert. Und da stand halt drin, dass ich drin bin wegen einem Überfall. Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben einen Überfall gemacht. Ich würde auch so etwas niemals machen. Ich meinte, okay, erst mal kommen die Akten und dann gucken wir uns das an. Dann kamen nach drei, vier Tagen die Akten. Kann man mich noch mal besuchen. Dann hat mir ein Telefonat gezeigt von mir und meinem Freund, der mich damals angerufen hat.
Also dieses Telefonat, was du am Anfang erzählt hast, das ist ein Freund, vor dem eine Straftat begangen hat, die am Telefon davon erzählt hat und du hast es dir angehört.
Aber ich habe mir gar nichts dabei gedacht. Ich dachte mir, okay, erzähl mir was davon. Ich habe auch nichts gemerkt, dass die irgendwie es aufgezeichnet haben. Aber die haben es auch alles aufgezeichnet, also aufgezeichnet, angehört. Danach haben wir auf einer ausländischen Sprache gesprochen und die haben es danach alles übersetzt und aufgeschrieben. Das waren so ungefähr zwei Seiten, stand drauf, Teilnehmer A und Teilnehmer B. Und da stand drauf Unbekannter und mein Name und meine Adresse und alles. Und dann meinte ich halt, was machen wir jetzt? Er meinte, du musst halt sagen, wer es ist, der dich angerufen hat. Weil da standen noch ganz viele falsche Sachen, was der Dolmetscher gesagt hat. Und die dachten, ich gehöre halt auch dazu. Die dachten, durch mich wissen die jetzt, wer derjenige ist, der mich angerufen hat. Okay, es war so ein Kumpel von mir aus. Von seinen ganzen Tagen wusste ich gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Und der Rest meinte, wenn es so ist, dann machen wir jetzt eine Haftprüfung. Und dann gucken wir halt, ob du raus kannst, was der Haftrichter entscheiden wird.
Wie ging das aus?
Da hatten wir eine Haftprüfung und so. Und die meinten, du musst halt warten bis zum Termin. Und ich meinte halt, der Junge heißt so und so. Und die sind dann halt zu denen nach Hause gegangen. Die haben geguckt, der ist nicht da. Okay, dann ging es weiter, bis der Termin endlich kam. Die haben ihn festgenommen. Und da habe ich die ganzen Akten gelesen. Es war so, dass der Junge, der ist halt in ein Taxi gestiegen. Einer hat die Nummernschrift gesehen. Die haben da angerufen, mein Taxi. Und danach haben die den Wagen kontrolliert und alles drum und dran, wer dieser Teilnehmer ist. Sie haben gesehen, dass der Freund, der mich angerufen hat, okay, der wurde festgenommen und der hat halt, er hat eine Strafe bekommen. Und ich wurde danach entlassen. Ja und seitdem, seit dem Tag, also kann ich nicht mehr irgendwie so ein Telefon führen, wo ich denke, dass das jetzt abgehört wird oder nicht.
Weil du glaubst, dass du jetzt quasi auch in einem Raster drin bist und dein Telefon routinemäßig auch abgehört wird.
Genau, dass sie denken, ich war halt schlau, ich hab mich da irgendwie zurückgehalten, hab's nicht gesagt und so, dass sie denken, der weiß noch mehr.
Okay, das ist vielleicht eine Frage an Sönke, unseren Rechtsanwalt. Kann ich in irgendeiner Form darauf einwirken? Kann ich sagen, ich möchte nicht, dass so was passiert? Also habe ich da Rechtsmittel als Privatmensch, wenn offensichtlich klar ist, eben wie bei René bei der Geschichte, dass ich damit nichts zu tun habe?
Ja klar, und du hast letztlich auch das Richtige gemacht. Du hast die Klappe gehalten, hast das Geschäft am Anwalt überlassen in einer ziemlich gefährlichen Situation für dich. Und es ist am Ende, das Warten hat sich gelohnt, auch für dich ja anscheinend gut ausgegangen. Die Entschädigung wird mäßig bis minimal sein, aber du hast dir nicht geschadet damit, wie du dich verhalten hast. Also das ist eigentlich schon mal das Gute an der Sache. Du hast keine Chance, dich da für die Zukunft gegen zu schützen. Aber eins solltest du vielleicht überlegen. Du hast hier mit deinem Verteidiger die Akte gesehen. Dann guck doch nochmal genauer rein. Wie ist es eigentlich gekommen, dass dieses Telefonat überwacht wurde? Also wer war eigentlich das Ziel der Überwachung? Warst du das aus einem völlig nichtigen Anlass oder zufällig oder aus einer technischen Panne oder was? Oder ist das vielleicht so, dass dein Gesprächspartner überwacht worden ist?
Nee, der hat ja, darfst du ihn zertrischen?
Ja bitte.
Also der hat jetzt Taxi angerufen und die wollten halt wissen, wer das war, der den Taxi angerufen hat. Okay, und weil die nicht wussten, wer das war, weil es irgendwie auf dem Handy, also der hat ja von Handy aus angerufen und der, der auf dieser Karte gemeldet war, das war nicht der, das war nicht mein Freund. Da haben die halt geguckt, wen der anruft und so und haben die gesehen, okay, da ist ein René und der wohnt da und da. Dann dachten die sich, okay, die nehmen mich fest, nehmen alles mit, was mitnehmenswert ist und so und ja.
Das heißt, du bist da reingerutscht quasi?
Genau, und ich saß dann uhaft, solange, obwohl ich nichts gemacht habe und die haben mir auch mein Zukunft verbaut, versaut. Ich war gerade mitten in einer Ausbildung und da kam ich zurück und meinte, ich war im Knast und so und die wollten nichts mit mir zu tun haben.
Ich würde sagen, die Staatsanwaltschaft schuldet dir einen Brief und deinen Arbeitgeber, den du von denen verlangen solltest, in dem drin steht, dass das alles eine Luftnummer war. Ich kann dich leider beunruhigen, dass du das Recht auf so einen Brief hast, aber vielleicht ist da doch mal bei den Staatsanwälten, die das versaut haben, ein offenes Wort gegenüber deinem Arbeitgeber auch angesagt. Du hast auch gewisse Entschehungsansprüche, das ist schwierig durchzusetzen, vor allem wenn es um so ätherische Sachen geht, die sozusagen kommen, Geld zu bezahlen sind, wie zum Beispiel, dass dein Ausbildungsplatz flöten gegangen ist. Aber vielleicht auf deine Eingangsfrage, das zeigt einfach nur, und das ist jetzt auch interessant für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, das zeigt einfach nur, dass man tierisch Pech haben kann und richtig fette Sachen abkriegen kann, ohne irgendwas damit zu tun zu haben. Und dafür machen wir heute so eine Sendung, dass euch zwar allen irgendwie klar ist, das kann passieren und da gibt es sozusagen Verhaltensregeln, wie man sich verhalten muss, aber ist es auch irgendwie klar, ihr könnt es nicht steuern. Das heißt aber auch für dich, dass du jetzt dein weiteres Leben nicht daran orientieren musst, dass dir das irgendwie theoretisch passieren könnte, weil es könnte mir genauso passieren, oder denen, die mit mir hier im Studio sind, oder all deinen Freunden. Lebe dein Leben und passe ein bisschen auf dich auf, aber du hast jetzt schon die Erfahrung, du hast nichts falsch gemacht.
Also was wir jetzt von deiner Geschichte, René, und auch natürlich von der Geschichte von Martin, glaube ich, mitgenommen haben in dieser ersten Stunde der Sendung, ist, dass diese allgemein angenommen, mir kann ja nichts passieren, ich habe ja nichts gemacht, Annahme sehr blauäugig ist, weil im Zweifelsfall hast du einfach Pech, stehst auf der falschen Seite der Straße und bist auf irgendeinem Foto mit drauf. Wir wollen jetzt überhaupt keine Panik machen, aber es kann eben passieren.
Vielleicht kannst du ja auch nochmal sagen, was heißt das eigentlich für dich jetzt? Du weißt ja, okay, sie haben dein Telefon mal abgehört, aber wie fühlst du dich da eigentlich?
Na ja, es kam halt so plötzlich und zum Beispiel ich mache irgendwas. Ich telefoniere oder ich bin im Internet oder ich spazier draußen nur mit meiner Freundin. Man weiß nie, ob man beobachtet wird oder irgendwas anderes. Und dann fühlte ich mich immer so, eigentlich mein ganzes Leben lang fühle ich mich so beobachtet. Verstehen Sie?
Das heißt, du hast schon eine gewisse Paranoia?
Wenn ich mit meiner Frau schlafe oder mit meiner Freundin jetzt verlobte oder irgendwas, dann weiß ich nie, ob da vielleicht irgendwelche Wanzen im Zimmer sind. Also soweit gehen die wirklich. Ich hab das auch mal so, okay, im Büchner gelesen, aber wenn ich denke, dass sie mein Telefon abhören, dann können die auch andere Sachen machen. Und die Frage ist ja, was man dahinter, also hinterher macht, wenn das alles irgendwie so bei mir, wo ich unschuldig war, und die mir so viele Sachen versaut haben. Auch, meine Mutter dachte auch ganz falsch von mir. Sie dachte gleich, okay, Überfälle und meine Familie und so.
Und das ist halt scheiße, aber...
Ach ne, vielleicht solltest du jetzt in der akuten Situation den Rat von Sönke, unserem Rechtsanwalt, befolgen und nochmal sozusagen mit dem Anwalt sprechen, der dich da beraten hat und diesen bei der Staatsanwaltschaft fragen, ob du einen Brief haben kannst, in dem drin steht, dass du nichts gemacht hast, damit du wenigstens diese Ausbildung weitermachen kannst.
Aber das war das Problem, weil der war ein Pflichtverteidiger, also vom Staat her bezahlt. Und ich kann mir halt das nicht leisten, einen neuen Rechtsanwalt zu holen. Aber dieses Formular, wo da drauf stand, das kommt halt diese, nicht diese Anklageschrift, wie heißt das? Dieser, am Ende dieses, was rauskommt.
Das war für eine Einstellungsentscheidung und die Aufhebung des Haftbefehls.
Genau, genau.
Ja, genau, das zeige ich dann halt so. Aber ich war halt selber erst mal durcheinander. Ich kam aus dem Knasthaus, ich meinte, okay, ich brauche das erst mal ein bisschen Ruhe und so. Und ich musste mich wieder, also wieder zu mir finden.
Krassige Geschichte, René. Danke, dass du dir erzählt hast.
Also ich habe eigentlich noch mehr erfahren, aber die stehe ich dann irgendwann. Wo kann man die, wo kann man euch erreichen?
Im Zweifelsfall kannst du eine Mail schicken an chaosradio at ccc.de. Danke für den Anruf. Tschüss René. Chaosradio am heutigen Mittwoch, dem 26. September, letzter Mittwoch vom Monat, das heißt der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast. Bei uns sind Frank und Constanze vom CCC weiterhin zu Gast. Ist Sönke Hilbrans, er ist Anwalt, Volker Eick ist auch da, er ist Politologe und Martin ist bei uns, der die Geschichte erzählt hat, wie er als unbescholtener Bürger, der von sich selbst sagt, wie wir auch so ekapärnisch gemacht, plötzlich das BKA im Haus, hatte die Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt haben. Und dazu machen wir heute auch diese Sendung, wie konkret funktioniert eigentlich diese Überwachung, von der so viele Leute reden dieser Tage, zu der es auch als Protest in der letzten Woche die große Demonstration in Berlin gab. Wie konkret funktioniert es eigentlich, wie sind eure Erfahrungen da in der Praxis und welche Fragen habt ihr dazu? Die könnt ihr stellen unter 0331 77 97 110. Wir werden nicht alle Fragen in jedem technischen Detail wirklich bis ins Letzte beantworten können, aber auch hier natürlich der Hinweis, Chaosradio at ccc.de, beziehungsweise ccc.de ist der Online-Kontakt, den ihr da gerne auch nutzen könnt. Frank Winkt.
Ja, also eine Frage, die mir noch so ein bisschen auf der Zunge brennt ist.
Hält Spuck's aus.
Diese Geschichte lief ja irgendwie offenbar sehr lange, also ein Jahr oder so was in der großen Klasse. Und du hast ja eine ganze Reihe von Überwachungsmaßnahmen aufgezählt.
Die Frage nur für Leute, die quasi es nicht sehen. Die Frage geht jetzt an Martin.
Genau, die da durchgeführt wurden. Haben die das alles auf einmal angemacht? Oder ist das jetzt so nach und nach irgendwie eskaliert worden? Oder wie muss man sich das dann tatsächlich praktisch vorstellen? Also ich meine, euer Wissen wird mir wahrscheinlich etwas begrenzt sein momentan noch.
Ja, das muss man Volker machen, glaube ich.
Man muss sich das, glaube ich, vorstellen wie so ein Schneeballsystem, die hier jetzt später zugeschaltet haben. Eine Person gerät aus irgendeinem Grund in Verdacht. Man guckt sich an, welche Leute kennt diese Person. Dann guckt man sich an, welche Leute die kennen. Und dann kommt man zu, um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen, der eine oder die andere hat das ja vielleicht mitgekriegt, als im Mai diesen Jahres 21 Leute beschuldigt worden sind, auch eine terroristische Vereinigung zu sein. Über 40 Wohnungen sind durchsucht worden, Buchläden und so weiter und so fort. Die haben dann irgendwann ihre Akten gekriegt, 33 Bände. Da stehen über 1000 Namen jetzt drin.
1000 Namen? Also für eine Gruppe, die beschuldigt wurde, hat sich dann natürlich gleich exponentiell erweitert.
Nicht mal eine Gruppe von diesen 21 Leuten kennt sich der große Teil überhaupt nicht. Die haben sich noch nie gesehen.
Also das ist quasi der statistische Effekt, den man natürlich hat, weil man ja jeder einzelne mit sehr vielen Menschen kommuniziert.
Ja, klar, Logo. Da kommt jetzt die Frage, die ich mir dann auch wieder stelle, als technischer Vollhorst. Du sagtest gerade, Volker, die Leute kennen sich untereinander gar nicht. Wenn bei einem geguckt wird, wer kennt den, dann guckt man den nicht. Stichwort MySpace-Profile. Ein Großteil von euch, die am Radio sitzen, werdet so ein Ding haben bzw. schon mal gehört haben, dass es sowas gibt. Ist es auch denkbar, dass man, wenn Eicke ins Visier kommt, dass man guckt, wer ist damit drauf? Und dann haben alle anderen Leute gleichzeitig auch eine Anfrage zu laufen? Ist sowas realistisch?
Also natürlich, wir haben es ja hier in dem Fall ohnehin gesehen, dass also Datenbestände von Firmen eben für die Ermittlung benutzt werden können.
Wir hatten ein Stichwort mit der Bahn zum Beispiel, mit Autovermietung.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Also klar, man kann ja die Unternehmen fragen. Wir haben aber eigentlich noch eine andere Diskussion, denn die Sicherheitspolitiker in Deutschland führen diesen, ich nenne es jetzt mal Web 2.0-Exhibitionismus oder auch die Tatsache, dass eben sehr viele Millionen Menschen in Deutschland eine Payback-Karte haben oder eine Happy-Digits-Karte, die führen diese Argumentation oft an und sagen sich, naja, die Menschen haben ja quasi freiwillig für diese privaten Datensammler ihre Daten rausgegeben. Also im Prinzip gibt es ja gar keinen Grund, warum nicht der Staat, dem man ja vertraut, diese Daten nicht eben auch haben sollte. Und da wird halt verkannt, dass man freiwillig privaten Firmen seine Daten gibt, aber dass die staatliche Form von Datensammler natürlich in keiner Weise freiwillig ist. Sondern man merkt sie ja teilweise nicht mehr und sie ist vor allen Dingen eben nicht freiwillig. Das heißt, man legt sich da nicht einen Account bei Myspace an, sondern natürlich werden die Daten hinter dem Rücken oder eben bei einem Verdacht gesammelt, ohne dass man da mitwirkt.
Und im Zweifelsfall hole ich mir irgendwo eine Paybackkarte, weil ich immer wieder frage werde, ob ich eine haben möchte, mit dem vorrangigen Ziel, irgendwann mal ein paar warme Socken oder eine Kaffeemaschine geschickt zu kriegen. Und dass es da irgendwo was Kleingedrucktes gibt, was ich mit unterschrieben habe, habe ich im Zweifelsfall in dem Moment einfach nicht gelesen und dann bin ich näse. Ja, letztes Jahr Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft, die Bedingung, dass man seine Personaldaten abgeben muss, damit man ein Ticket kriegt, mal ganz davon abgesehen, wie überhaupt die Zugangsbedingungen für Normalsterbliche zum Stadion waren. Wo die dann anfühlen, da ist es nicht kleingedruckt, das ist großgedruckt und wir haben euch ja zweimal gefragt, aber der Fakt bleibt, dass diese ganzen hochsensiblen Daten weiterverkauft werden und quasi die FIFA noch mal extra Geld mit den Daten dieser Leute macht, ohne dass sie irgendeinen Einfluss darauf haben, was mit diesen Daten dann passiert. Und wenn sie Glück haben, ist es nur Werbemüll in Briefkasten.
Ist denn dieses Aufblähen der Anzahl der Verdächtigen, verwenden die da auch Informationen aus dem Internet oder arbeiten die da nur auf der Basis von Telefondaten?
Nee, nee, noch ist das Publizieren in Deutschland nicht verboten. Das heißt, im Zuge des 21. Jahrhunderts, ich bin froh, dass ich das 19. Jahrhundert überwunden habe, publiziert man natürlich auch im Internet. Man publiziert natürlich mit wissenschaftlichen Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch international über E-Mail. Ich kann mich zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, wie ich mit Kollegen früher in den USA oder Großbritannien kommuniziert habe. Das hat alles Ewigkeiten gedauert mit Briefen und so weiter und so fort. Natürlich macht man das. Man geht ja nicht davon aus, dass man da ein Problem mitkriegen könnte.
Habt ihr denn in diesem Zusammenhang Techniken verwendet, um eure Privatsphäre zu schützen, etwa E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
In dem Moment kommt dann auch Sebastian ran, der wissen will, wie sicher heutzutage Verschlüsselungen sind. Sebastian, halt durch, du bist der nächste.
Jetzt deine Frage, Entschuldigung. Also, ich frage jetzt mal Martin, hast du deine E-Mails verschlüsselt?
Also, ich selber habe nie verschlüsselt, aber ich habe jetzt irgendwie nach dem Aktenstudium gemerkt, dass das Sachen sind, die das BKA total heiß machen. Also, eine große Begründung sozusagen für diese Ermittlungsverfahren ist neben der Übereinstimmung von irgendwelchen Wörtern das Stichwort konspiratives Verhalten. Und das definieren die auch nicht. Und dazu gehört alles, wenn irgendwie Leute versuchen, ihre Privatsphäre zu schützen.
Dann hast du möglicherweise sowas zu verbergen.
Also, die selber verschlüsseln oder verschlüsselte Chats benutzen oder, oder, oder, oder, anonyme, also den eigenen Namen nicht im E-Mail-Header oder sowas, da sind die total heiß drauf. Und das benutzen sie dann auch als Begründung nach dem Motto, wie können wir jetzt das Verfahren irgendwie weiterführen? Wir haben zwar sonst nichts gefunden, aber der verhält sich hier ganz konspirativ. Und da beißt sich natürlich auch die Katze im Schwanz. Einerseits wird da ein Riesenermittlungsapparat aufgebaut. Und wenn Leute dann aus dem kritischen Bewusstsein heraus überlegen, wie können wir hier ein bisschen sorgfältiger mit unseren eigenen Daten umgehen, dann ist das sofort Konspiration, Konspiration.
Okay, also Daten verschlüsseln war früher mal wichtig. Daten nicht verschlüsseln macht dich in dem Moment gleich auch mal, ich sage mal, verdächtig, in Anführungszeichen. Was soll man tun? Wir fragen mal Sebastian. Sebastian hat angerufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und er kommt aus Berlin. Name, Sebastian. Verschlüsseln oder nicht verschlüsseln?
Also das ist jetzt eigentlich so meine große Frage, die ich so hatte. Also ganz generell wollte ich eigentlich auch nochmal nur appellieren, finde ich, dass die ganzen Leute eigentlich viel bewusster mit ihren Daten umgehen sollten. Also gerade auch jetzt, als diese Payback-Geschichte kam und so weiter, was dieses, weiß ich, Customer-Tracking oder dieses ganze Kaufverhalten und so weiter, wie das alles gelockt und verfolgt wird und so, dass sich die Leute eigentlich gar nicht bewusst sind, was sie davon sich preisgeben und so und eigentlich so viel mit sich machen lassen.
Alles für ein paar warme Socken.
Und immer diese Sache, ja, ich habe da nichts zu befürchten, sodass es ihnen eigentlich völlig egal ist, wer hier irgendwelche Daten hat und also das verstehe ich alles nicht.
Zum Thema, ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz auf den Anfang der Sendung hinweisen, zum Thema ich habe noch nichts zu befürchten, haben wir heute im Chaosradio gesagt Martin da, der gerade seine Geschichte erzählt hat und vor wenigen Minuten hat er auch René angerufen, der unter anderem Vorzeichen eine ähnliche Geschichte erzählt hat, wo er sagte, ich habe damit überhaupt nichts zu tun und plötzlich stand, plötzlich war er quasi mit dem Visier. So, deine Frage, Entschuldigung.
Ja, meine Frage ist eigentlich, wie, also sinnvoll ist es, also abgesehen davon, dass man vielleicht eher doch ins Visier gerät dann bei so Sachen, aber ich eigentlich permanent, wenn ich jemanden habe, der auch mit verschlüsselt bzw. also über GNU-PG meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel hat und so weiter und das alles macht, dann mache ich das auf jeden Fall. Ich bin auch dabei, weil ich eben auch überlegt habe, wie sichert man seine Daten, egal, ob ich da was verheimlichen will oder nicht. Ich will einfach nicht, dass irgendjemand das sieht und schon gar nicht der Staat. Und mir ist es eben nichts, den Rechner aus dem Netz zu holen. Also was hat man da für Alternativen, irgendwie muss man es ja immer, ich habe nicht Lust wegen jeder kleinen Sache irgendwie auf dem USB-Stick zu tun.
Sebastian, wo kommt dein Fragezeichen?
Mein Fragezeichen kommt, wie sicher ist es? Also man hört zwar immer...
Wie sicher ist die Verschlüsselung von...
Genau, also wenn ich mir auf Dateien zum Beispiel mit TrueCrypte, dann gibt es alle möglichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren, wenn ich die anwende, AIS, wie auch immer, alle Leute sagen, ach ja, BKA, die klacken das sowieso.
Also der...
Frage an den Chaos Computer Club, an Frank.
Ja, also die Sicherheit von unterschiedlichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren schwankt natürlich stark. Wenn man halbwegs vertrauenswürdige, gut belommnete Verschlüsselungsverfahren verwendet, kann man in der Regel sagen, ist die Sicherheit so gut wie dein Passwort? Das heißt also dein, also jetzt mal ausgehend von der Frage, du hast jetzt ganz angenommen, dass kein Online-Trojaner, keine Computer-Wanze auf deinem Computer ist, ist bei guten Verschlüsselungsverfahren die Sicherheit deiner Verschlüsselung so gut wie dein Passwort?
Das heißt, ich nehme nicht Mutti21?
Genau, weil das ist das, was zumindest nach meiner Kenntnis die Strafverfolgungsbehörden halt auch tun, dass sie tatsächlich versuchen, Passworte zu raten oder halt aus dem Umfeld irgendwie Passworte zu generieren. Sie versuchen natürlich auch technische Tricks und Kniffe anzuwenden, um halt zum Beispiel Passworte, die noch im Cache sind oder die auf die Platte geswapft wurden und andere Dinge mehr zu kriegen. Also man muss sich da halt schon Gedanken darüber machen, wie es halt funktioniert. Dass Verschlüsselung direkt im geheimnützlichen Sinne per kriptoanalytischen Attacke gebrochen wurde, ist mir zumindest aus dem Strafverfolgungsbereich nicht bekannt.
Ist mir auch noch nichts bekannt.
Also das ist ja auch gerade der Grund, wo wir auch ja letztes Mal bei Sönke noch mal drüber gesprochen haben, der Grund, warum diese Computer-Wanze, die ja auch Bundes-Trojaner oder Online-Durchsuchung genannt wird, etabliert werden soll. Weil genau an die verschlüsselten Daten, wenn die mit einem guten Passwort geschützt sind, eben kein Zugang möglich ist.
Also gute Verschlüsselung plus gutes Passwort. Allgemein kann man sagen, wenn die Geheimdienste Verschlüsselungen brechen können, erzählen sie niemandem, auch nicht den Strafverfahrensbehörden. Also das ist halt so, weil dann müssten sie zugeben, dass diese Verschlüsselung schwach ist. Das würde in einem Strafverfahren rauskommen, das würden sie halt niemals zugeben.
Also um das andere zu beantworten, Sebastian, die Verschlüsselung ist immer nur so gut A wie dein Passwort und B so gut, wie du dich selber gut fühlst dabei.
Okay, und alphanomenisch 20 Ziffern laufe ich gut, oder?
Wenn es hinhör ich, das klingt zufällig.
Wenn du dir die alle merken kannst?
Also ein guter Weg zum Beispiel, sowas zu tun, ist sich einen schönen langen Satz zu nehmen, den man sich merken kann und davon irgendwie, was ist sich den Anfangsbuchstaben, den dritten Buchstaben, den letzten Buchstaben, so ein paar Zahlenreinwürfe oder dergleichen Dinge.
Also ich kann das doch sehr gut mit reimen, also längere Reime, etwa so nett, das kann man sich dann noch sehr gut merken.
Und dann fällt dir leider die 538. Schrofe von der Glocke nicht ein und dann hast du ein Problem, da kommst du mit einem Passwort. Das ist kein so nett. Sebastian, ganz kurz zum Schluss an dich, die Frage, die mir gerade in den Kopf kommt. Wir reden so viel über diesen Bundes-Trojaner, über dieses Virus, was auf Computer raufgeht und der hat so viele Namen. Wollen wir dem nicht mal einen Namen geben?
Computer-Wanze.
Ach, Computer-Wanze ist so unsexy. Den kann man auch wie nennen? Den kann man Horst nennen oder Erwin oder Schnuffi oder so. Na ja, dann nennst du eben Schnuffi. Schnuffi heißt keiner. Gut, Sebastian, vielen Dank für den Anruf. 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz, wir reden heute darüber, wie konkret die Überwachung der Bürger mit ihren E-Mail-Kontakten, ihren, wie hast du das schon gesagt, Constanze, vorhin Fernmelde-Daten, heißt das so? Nee, wie heißt denn das? Telekommunikations-Fern-Dingst-Bolus?
Telekommunikations-Verbindungs-Daten.
Ja, wie sowas genau in der Praxis funktioniert. Wir haben heute schon einige Geschichten gehört, einige Fragen auch bekommen, wenn ihr die habt, könnt ihr die gerne stellen an uns. Die nächste Frage kommt von Roman aus Neukölln.
Ja, ich wollte auf den vorverletzten Anruf antworten, der wissen wollte, was er beachten muss, wenn er ins Internet geht.
Ja, genau, das war die Frage. Ich habe jetzt einen Rechner, der geht neu ans Netz, was soll ich machen?
Ja, ich würde ihm raten, als erstes TV in Kino Linux installieren, weil da kriegen die Klaglager euch, dass es unwahrscheinlicher ist, dass die da einen Bundesprojaner draufkriegen.
Das heißt, nicht die gängigen Betriebssysteme wie Mac OS oder Windows zu benutzen?
Auf jeden Fall würde ich ihn von Windows abraten, weil die da wahrscheinlich am meisten Einfallstüren haben. Das schließt aber noch nicht aus, also wenn er Linux nutzt, dann können die immer noch herausfinden, was bei ihm auf der Platte liegt, wenn sie eine Hausdurchsuchung, eine klassische Hausdurchsuchung mitnehmen. Dagegen hilft, wenn er sein verbotenes Video, was er hat, da frage ich mich, was das eigentlich sein könnte. Weil eigentlich sind ja nur Kinderbrotten verboten. Wenn er irgendwelche Kinderbrotten hat, die sollte er nur zum Anspielen, zum Abspielen unverschließend liegen lassen.
Moment, wir gehen jetzt mal nicht davon aus, dass irgendjemand, der hier anruft, so einen Scheiß auf der Platte hat. Also wollen wir mal kurz klarstellen.
Naja, ob das Scheiß ist oder nicht, darüber kann man sich streiten.
Darüber müssen wir glaube ich nicht streiten. Okay, also deine Anmerkung war in jedem Fall Linux anstatt von Mac OS und auf keinen Fall Windows.
Und verboten das Video mit PGG-Verschlüsseln und neben Dateinamen geben, der unverdächtig ist.
Guter Tipp. Wir haben jetzt schon sehr viel über so Geschichten gesprochen, wie das im Technischen funktioniert mit dem Bundestrojaner zum Beispiel, mit sonstigen Dingen der Überwachung. Die Frage, die immer noch nicht wirklich geklärt ist, ist, wie kriege ich das mit, dass ich möglicherweise im Beobachtungsfadenkreuz stehe.
Also wenn es jetzt nur um die Computerwanze geht, dann ist natürlich gerade das Ansinnen der Ermittlungsbehörden, dass man es nicht mitbekommt. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass diese handelsüblichen Firewalls oder Anti-Viren-Programme natürlich nicht gegen so eine individualisierte Spionage-Software helfen. Na klar. Aber wenn man jetzt den Fall von Martin sieht, wo man ja nicht nur diese eine Möglichkeit genommen hat, sondern einfach mal alles, was technisch ging, dann gibt es vielleicht schon Möglichkeiten. Da können wir vielleicht ja Martin mal direkt fragen. Hattest du vorab irgendwelche Ideen, dass dich vielleicht jemand abhören könnte oder kam es wirklich total aus der Kalt? Hast du mal jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet Anhaltspunkte dafür gesehen?
So verdächtige Schleitende in der Ecke oder irgendwie sowas?
Ich glaube, wenn man da nicht extrem hinterher ist und nun total paranoid, kriegt man das einfach nicht mit. Und dass jetzt jemand paranoid ist, heißt ja nicht, dass er nicht verfolgt wird.
Also du kannst sagen, du warst arglos, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen kann.
Das ist eine Suggestivfrage.
Auf jeden Fall bin ich von einer Hausdurchsuchung überrascht worden.
Also es ist ja vielleicht natürlich immer ein Wir-kennen-Fälle, wo mal was schiefgegangen ist, etwa bei der Abrechnung und der Übersendung von Rechnung von Telefonfirmen, sowas haben wir mal gehört. Es ist uns auch bekannt geworden, dass dann mal eben dadurch die Abhörmaßnahme bekannt geworden ist. Aber in der Regel ist natürlich der Sinn der Sache, dass man es nicht mitbekommt und in der Regel wird man es auch nicht mitbekommen. Immer erst dann, wenn es zu einem Verfahren kommt und ein Anwalt vielleicht irgendwie Einsicht nehmen kann, dann erfährt man es halt.
Nur ist diese Sendung nicht ganz, weil es gibt ja durchaus den Fall, dass sie wollen, dass du weißt, dass du überwacht wirst, um dir Panik zu machen, um dich einzuschüchtern oder sonst irgendwas noch zu machen.
Es gibt natürlich noch eine Sache, die man in dem Zusammenhang erwähnen muss. Die meisten, eigentlich alle dieser Bewachungsmaßnahmen sind per Gesetz mit einer nachträglichen Benachrichtigungspflicht versehen. Entsprechend müssten eigentlich die Ermittlungsbehörden diese Benachrichtigungen senden, aber praktisch und wir haben es auch gerade in einer wissenschaftlichen Studie wieder erfahren, wird das dann weniger als ein Drittel der Fälle überhaupt getan.
Das heißt, Martin hätte quasi drei Tage später einen Brief bekommen müssen, in dem drin stand, hallo, wir waren übrigens in deiner Wohnung.
Ne, so natürlich nicht. Das passiert dann erst, wenn das ganze Verfahren abgeschlossen ist und es gibt halt sehr viele Ausnahmen, die der Gesetzgeber da schon in die Gesetze reingeschrieben hat, weswegen sie eben nicht benachrichtigen, etwa wenn sie ein anderes Strafverfahren damit gefährden, wenn sie einen V-Mann aufdecken würden. Es sind immer eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten und das wird schlicht und nur weniger als ein Drittel der Fälle getan.
Gesetzgeber und Gesetze, kommt sofort unser Rechtsanwalt Sönke und meldet sich zu Wort.
Naja, vor allem, ich habe immer so einen Eindruck, dass diese nachträglichen Benachrichtigungen gar nicht dazu passieren, um den Betroffenen irgendwie noch nachträglich eine Chance zu geben, sich zur Wehr zu setzen oder sonst irgendwie die Interessen der Betroffenen noch irgendwie zu schützen oder zu berücksichtigen. Die Fälle von nachträglichen Mitteilungen, die mir so bekannt geworden sind, hatten vor allem katastrophale Folgen für die Betroffenen selber. Da sind nämlich nicht nur die Betroffenen benachrichtigt worden, sondern auch alle anderen Gesprächsteilnehmer. Das sind also dann die Situationen eingetreten, dass Leute, die sich überhaupt nicht zur Schulden kommen haben lassen, völlig unschuldig in ein Ermittlungsverfahren geraten sind, deren Telefonate sind abgehört worden. Das hat man ihnen dann nachher mitgeteilt, so weit, so grausam, aber immerhin, es gab die Mitteilung. Und wem hat man das noch alles mitgeteilt? Dem ganzen sozialen Umfeld, deren Telefonnummer man ja schließlich auch hat und deren Namen man zum Teil hatte. Und dann wusste das ganze soziale Umfeld, dass irgendeine schwere Straftat verfolgt wurde und dass man den Anschluss eben der Unschuldigen abgehört hat. Das ist also die Rufschädigung noch im Nachhinein trotz erwiesener Umschuld, die mit solchen Benachrichtigungen dann auch verbunden sein kann. Das Instrument geht also in diesen Fällen völlig nach hinten los und der gute Wille absolut in die Hose. Und den Betroffenen selber ist damit fast noch mehr geschadet, als wenn man sie über Auskunft betätigt.
Also hast du wirklich diesen Eindruck, weil wir haben so eine Diskussion mit Politikern, wenn halt dieses Thema angesprochen wird, immer den Eindruck, dass halt eher massiv vermieden wird, diese Mitteilung zu machen, um einfach das ganze Ausmaß dessen, wie viel überwacht wird, tatsächlich überhaupt nicht deutlich werden zu lassen?
Das stimmt schon, das wird massiv vermieden, aber in den Fällen, wo dann doch Informationen rausgehen, dann schaden sie den Betroffenen noch mehr. Natürlich ist es in der Sache völlig richtig, es werden nur eine Handvoll Prozent von geheimen Ermittlungsmaßnahmen tatsächlich den Betroffenen auch bekannt und dann naja in den meisten Fällen dann eher auch im Haftbefehl oder in der Anklageschrift, aber nicht dadurch, dass sie es nachher nochmal nachträglich trotz erwiesener Unschuld erfahren.
Sönke, wir hören jetzt genau zu was ich sage, nicht, dass ich Blödsinn erzähle, aber worüber wir heute in dieser Sendung reden, sind nicht irgendwie Straftaten, die wirklich passieren, die auch zu verfolgen sind und die zu ahnden sind, sondern wir reden darüber, dass Leute, die offensichtlich unschuldig sind bzw. mit einer bestimmten Sache nichts zu tun haben, durch Zufälle mit ins Raster der Observierung, der Überwachung reinrutschen und dann die Folgen damit zu tragen haben. Hab ich das richtig jetzt zugedreht? Dazu haben wir nämlich einen Anruf aus Schweinfurt aus Franken von Christoph. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend, hallo.
Grüße dich. Wir sind jetzt nämlich genau bei dem Punkt, wo ich glaube, dass du darüber reden möchtest, dass man kalte Füße bekommt bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Genau, ich habe einfach nur Angst. Ich habe einfach nur Angst. Es geht mir darum, dass ich jetzt nicht der Kriminelle bin oder der Typ, der irgendwas schwer wegen des Todes und Gottes will, mir geht es einfach nur, ich habe einfach nur Angst. Ich erfahre nicht, dass ich überwacht werde, dass ich abgehört werde. Es werden vielleicht auch Profite erstellt, man weiß es nicht. Meine Angst ist halt dahingehend, dass ich einfach nicht weiß. Ich werde meine persönlichen Freiheiten irgendwo eingeschränkt und ich habe einfach meine Angst, dass ich mein Leben nicht mehr selbstbestimmt irgendwann leben kann. Ich habe einfach die Angst, ich kann nicht entscheiden. Man kann sich dagegen auch schlecht werden, würde ich sagen, weil es entwickelt sich alles irgendwo hin. Man weiß es nicht, wozu es irgendwann gut sein wird.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite den Kopf einzuziehen und zu sagen, es wird alles sowieso irgendwann passieren und es ist alles schlimm, das ist ja auch nicht der Weg, den man gehen sollte.
Es ist nicht der Weg, ich sage irgendwann der Weg, wo jeder so… Was will man dagegen tun? Irgendwann hat sich so etwas entwickelt und keiner kann mehr was dagegen machen.
Na ja, dazu machen wir ja Sendungen wie diese, um zumindest über diese Vorgänge aufzuklären.
Also es ist natürlich nicht so, dass man nichts machen kann. Also den Kopf in den Sand stecken kann nicht die Antwort sein. Und wir haben ja gerade diesen Samstag in Berlin bei der Demo gesehen, dass wir eben nicht alleine sind, sondern wir waren da eben 10.000. Das heißt, man muss kommunizieren, dass einen diese Entwicklung hin zu einem Überwachungsstaat stört. Wir sind diejenigen, die die Volksvertreter wählen. Wir können uns auch an die wenden. Wir können uns politisch engagieren. Also wir vom Chaos Computer Club tun dies. Natürlich würde ich nicht behaupten, wir sind total toll erfolgreich und würden da viel erreichen, aber ich denke, dass nur, wenn wir hier einen Konsens herstellen, wenn die Mehrheit sagt, nein, wir wollen hier nicht so abgeschnorchelt werden, nur dann wird sich was ändern.
Da bin ich auch voll dahinter. Ich bin da auf jeden Fall einer, der voll dahinter steht, weil man will ja auch irgendwo tun lassen, was man möchte. Man möchte sein Leben in die eigene Hand nehmen.
Ja, du musst es schlicht artikulieren, und zwar überall. In deinem Freundeskreis, in deinem Familienkreis, in dem Webblog, was du vielleicht hast, und deinem Abgeordneten. Also das ist schlicht einfach, man muss es sagen. Wir leben schließlich immer noch an so weit in der Demokratie, dass wir es offen sagen dürfen.
Genau, ich habe schon bei mir eine Familie mit diskutiert, und mein Vater befasst sich da ja auch mit dem Thema. Der Vater ist mittlerweile schon 55, und der hat ja früher irgendwas zur Neu-Welt-Ordnung und irgendwas geredet, man weiß nie. Ich kriege da mittlerweile Angst, dass es ein Puzzle-Stein zu allem sein könnte. Und naja, man weiß nie, gell?
Im Zweifelsfall ist entweder eine Mail oder ein Brief an deinen lokalen Datenschutzbeauftragten oder aber deinen örtlichen Volksvertreter in Speinfurt schon ein Anfang, das du sagen kannst, das gefällt mir nicht. Alles klar. Danke für den Anruf, Christoph. Der nächste Anruf kommt wieder aus Berlin und zwar von Stefan. Guten Abend Stefan.
Guten Abend.
Grüße dich. Wir werden jetzt wieder ein bisschen detaillierter und reden über Mail-Systeme.
Ja genau, das ist eigentlich ein Thema, was mich sehr interessiert. Es ist ja doch sehr verbreitet, dass man Anbieter, sagen wir mal, wie Yahoo oder Ruhi oder was auch immer nutzt. Also ich sage jetzt mal speziell Yahoo und mich würde mal interessieren, wie das von den Extarten, die jetzt im Studio sitzen, was so eingeschätzt wird, wenn man also Yahoo benutzt, insbesondere jetzt vom E-Mails zu empfangen und um sie halt zu verschicken. Wie sicher ist das? Oder sind da Gefahren vorhanden? Ich habe zum Beispiel aktuell speziell, dass ich irgendwelche merkwürdigen Mails erhalte, wo es heißt, es wird nun Geld von meinem Konto abgebucht, die ich dann auch ignoriere. Aber ich kriege sehr viele komische Meals, teilweise auch irgendwelche Erotikangebote, wo ich gar nicht weiß, woher die kommen. Also das interessiert mich jetzt mal speziell, wie wird das so gesehen von den Fachleuten?
Das heißt, du kriegst einen Haufen Spam und willst wissen, warum?
Das habe ich jetzt akustisch nicht verstanden.
Du kriegst einen Haufen Spam, also ungewünschte Mails, du wirst zugemüllt mit Werbung und sonstigen Anfragen und weißt nicht warum und würdest gerne wissen, wo die herkommen?
Ja, das ist sicherlich ein Grund, sage ich mal, aber mich beschäftigt eigentlich mehr der Gedanke, wie gefährlich ist das, dass aufgrund so einer Mail praktisch mein System irgendwie gehackt wird, also praktisch, dass jemand in meine vorhandenen Mails, die ich bei Yahoo! drin habe, reingelangt, und dass ich das wünsche. Das ist mir eigentlich wichtiger. So eine Spam-Mail ist sicherlich nicht schön, aber die kann man dann auch löschen.
Okay, reden wir nicht über Spam und fragen wir am besten jemanden, der das absolut weiß, nämlich Frank vom CCC.
Eigentlich ist das nicht so richtig unser Thema heute hier. Der E-Mail ist halt ein riskantes Kommunikationsmedium. Wenn du irgendwie der Sicherheit deines Systems nicht hier sicher sein kannst, solltest du nicht auf unbekannte Anhänge klicken. Du kannst in jedem Fall davon ausgehen, dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden genau kein Problem haben, die E-Mail bei Yahoo! oder wem auch immer darauf zuzugreifen. Und wenn dein Passwort bei Yahoo! nicht besonders sicher ist, dann im Zweifel auch irgendwie der Rest der Welt. Letztendlich ist die Nachricht, du musst dich halt darum kümmern, such dir halt einen ordentlichen E-Mail-Anbieter, der halt irgendwie...
Was wären ordentliche E-Mail-Anbieter?
E-Mail-Anbieter, die sich halt darum kümmern, dass sie ordentliche Spam-Filter haben und man halt eben nicht zugemüllte Postfläche hat. Und ein E-Mail-Client, der halt nicht irgendwie jedes Attachment automatisch aufmacht. Also zum Beispiel halt irgendwie Thunderbird benutzen anstatt Outlook Express.
Also Thunderbird statt Outlook Express und für einen E-Mail-Anbieter vielleicht noch einen Tipp, weil wir müssen sowieso Nachrichten machen.
Ja, such dir einen aus, gibt genügend die halt irgendwie...
Letzte Frage nochmal, besteht denn die Gefahr dann erst, wenn man den Anhang öffnet oder nur wenn man die E-Mail aufmacht?
Das hängt von deinem E-Mail-Client ab, wenn du halt irgendwie Outlook oder ähnliche verwendest, dann kann es halt auch passieren, dass das schon losgeht, wenn du nur die E-Mail aufmachst.
Also Augen auf und Mails zu.
Ich bedanke mich.
Danke Stefan, tschüss.
Schönen Abend.
Hallo und ich bin ein Trailersprecher. Und jetzt machen wir einen Trailer. Dein Konzert, richtig? Ab 19 Uhr in Fritzlub im Postbahnhof, direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Mehr Infos fritz.de This is gonna get us high Okay, money brother, that's all.
You've been prima.
Und das hört man zwei nachher zwölf Uhr. Mit Liane Gruß.
Nachdem bei den Massenprotesten in Börmer mindestens acht Menschen von Sicherheitskräften erschossen worden, bereitet der UN-Sicherheitsrat auf einer Sondersitzung. Generalsekretär Bann kündigte die Entsendung seines Sonderbeauftragten an. Außerdem rief er die Militärregierung erneut zur Zurückhaltung gegenüber den friedlichen Demonstranten auf. Der Bundesgerichtshof hat ein Grundsatzurteil zum Unterhalt nach Scheidungen getroffen. Die Richter urteilten, dass der Besserverdienende nicht lebenslang für den früheren Partner sorgen muss. Mit dieser Entscheidung werden zeitlich befristete Unterhaltszahlungen erlaubt. Aber der wirtschaftlich schlechter gestellte, soll der Besserverdienende nicht lebenslang für den früheren Partner sorgen muss. Mit dieser Entscheidung werden zeitlich befristete Unterhaltszahlungen erlaubt. Aber der wirtschaftlich schlechter gestellte, sollte sich langfristig mit dem begnügen, was er selbst erwirtschafte. Die Bundesregierung hat vor den Risiken gefälschter Produkte gewarnt. Mittlerweile seien auch hierzulande nachgemacht und auch gefährliche Medikamente aufgetaucht, erklärte Bundesjustizministerin Zypries. Gesundheitsgefährdend ist häufig auch Kleidung, weil illegale Zusatzstoffe Allergien auslösen könnten. Zudem verursachten die gefälschten Waren massive wirtschaftliche Schäden. Zypries stellte heute ein neues Internetportal vor, wo sich Unternehmen und Verbraucher über Produktpiraterie informieren können. Zum Sport. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen steht im WM-Finale. Die Titelverteidigerinnen gewannen das Halbfinale gegen Norwegen mit 3 zu 0. Und in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Energie Cottbus eine Niederlage einstecken müssen. Der Tabellenletzte verlor auswärts gegen den Tabellenersten Bayern München mit 0 zu 5. Die weiteren Ergebnisse. Nürnberg gegen Leverkusen 1 zu 2, Stuttgart-Bochum 1 zu 0, Frankfurt-Karsruhe 0 zu 1 und Bielefeld gegen Hannover 0 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Angermünde und Wittenberge 10 Grad, Potsdam 11 Grad, Frankfurt 12 Grad und Cottbus und Neuropin 13 Grad, ebenfalls in Berlin 13 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es meist wolkig. Im Süden Brandenburgs kann es etwas Regen geben. Die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 10 bis 8 Grad. Morgen soll es dann meist wolkig bleiben. Ab und zu kann es regnen bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Auf den Straßen ist alles ruhig. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBEB.
Und wann im Radio 101, 5? Dann fritz im Eisenhüttenstadt.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Schauspieler, ich bin ein Schauspieler. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, ich bin ein Schauspieler. Ich bin ein Schauser, ich bin ein Schauser. Ich bin ein Schauser, ich bin ein Schauser. Dann ist bei uns Sönke Hilbrans, er ist Rechtsanwalt. Und dann ist bei uns auch noch Martin, der ganz am Anfang der Sendung die Geschichte erzählt hat, wie er einen Anruf bekam, dass bei ihm zu Hause eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt wird. Hintergrund war der, dass er Kontakt hatte mit Leuten, die wiederum sich über ganz obskure Geschichten möglicherweise, ich bin da sehr konjunktiv, verdächtig gemacht haben sollten. Und in der allgemeinen Überwachung war sein Name eben mit dabei. Und plötzlich stand das BKA bei ihm in der Wohnung und hat eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt. Ihr seht, wir reden über Überwachung durch den Staat, wir reden über den Bundestrojaner, wir reden über E-Mail-Speicherung, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die ganzen Geschichten. Und wenn ihr da Fragen habt, dann können wir die gerne klären. Eine ist gekommen per Mail und zwar von Martin, der sagt, gibt es eigentlich einen ausländischen Free-Mail-Anbieter außerhalb der EU, bei dem keine Verbindungsdaten gespeichert werden?
Frank? Also keiner, der mir wirklich bekannt ist, weil die großen Free-Mail-Anbieter sind alle in Staaten, in denen es vergleichbare Gesetze gibt. Also in den USA oder Kanada oder Skandinavien und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also es gibt sicherlich ein paar kleinere, die etwas restriktiver vorgehen und sagen, wir wollen wirklich eine gerichtliche Anordnung haben und antworten nicht auf jedes Fax, aber da ändert sich die Lage auch fortlaufend. Da muss man halt einfach mal ein bisschen selber recherchieren.
Also Antwort ist eher ein Nein.
Nicht wirklich so.
Ein leicht rosanes Vielleicht.
Genau.
Martin Koffer, wir haben die Frage an dem Moment für dich hinreichend beantwortet. Frank hat da aber noch eine andere Geschichte, die er ansprechen wollte.
Ja genau, und zwar was der Volker früher erzählt, war diese Geschichte, dass ja eine große Menge von Überwachungsmaßnahmen angewendet wurden. Du erwähntest Kameras vom Haus, GPS und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Wurde das denn alles auf einmal angewendet oder haben die das so nach und nach gesteigert?
Antwort ich jetzt mal drauf. Nee, das ging nach und nach. Also die müssten alle drei Monate, mussten Bundesrichter diese Maßnahmen verlängern. Und der Ablauf war schon so, dass sie am Anfang erst mal für die ersten vier Beschuldigten alles geholt haben. Dann haben sie nach drei Monaten gemerkt, außer Kontakten unter den Beschuldigten und in Bezug auf Verfahren haben wir gar nichts rausgekriegt. Also brauchen wir mehr. Und dann wurde das sukzessive über das ganze Jahr immer wieder weiter gesteigert. Also immer mehr Kameras, immer mehr GPS-Verwandtungen. Irgendwann wurden die Telefonanschlüsse der Freundinnen mit dazu genommen.
Haben sie das irgendwie begründet?
Die Begründung lautet immer Stereotyp. Wir konnten hier wichtige Erkenntnisse gewinnen über Kontakte der Beschuldigten untereinander sowie über ihre politischen Tätigkeiten und so weiter. Also nichts, was im Bezug auf den Vorwurf eigentlich relevant wäre.
Im Zuge dessen kommt noch mal die Frage, die wir jetzt auch möglicherweise gleich am Telefon noch mal klären müssen, haben, die in der Sendung immer wieder auftaucht, kriegt man raus, dass man überwacht wird? Die ist heute schon so oft gefallen, aber Leute schalten rein und raus, deswegen vielleicht jetzt noch mal die Antwort dazu, bevor wir zum nächsten Anruf bekommen. Ja, wenn überhaupt, beziehungsweise wie ich vorhin schon sagte, wenn sie es wollen. Und die Frage ist, ob irgendjemand will, dass man dir mithält, dass du überwacht wirst. Also entweder aus Gründen, um dich einzuschüchtern oder quasi in der Erwartung, dass du verunsichert bist und dann nicht weißt, was du machen sollst und so weiter und so fort. Nur in unserem Verfahren ist es so, dass quasi diese Eskalationslawine, die die da nach und nach losgetreten haben, ja dazu geführt hat, dass, weil gegen die Leute nichts gefunden worden ist, sie sich jetzt auch wieder verdächtig machen.
Ich meine, es gibt noch so eine Art taktische Aufklärung, dass also dann über Presseorgane, ja über bestimmte Presseorgane, dann rauskommt, dass es in einem bestimmten Zusammenhang irgendwo ein Verfahren und Überwachung gibt. Und das kann man sich vielleicht auch vorstellen als eine wirklich taktische Maßnahme. Dann mal gucken, was dann passiert, welche, wie die Szene darauf reagiert, wie die Leute darauf reagieren, die man direkt angesprochen hat, und daraus dann vielleicht Lüste zu ziehen.
Das heißt also, die publizieren irgendwo ein Artikel, Munkel, Munkel, da gibt es irgendein Verfahren, böser Terrorismus, und dann guckt man, wie er irgendwie hektisch anfängt, nicht mehr zu telefonieren?
Jedenfalls wundert man sich manchmal, wie so bestimmte eigentlich streng geheime Ermittlungen von meiner Zeitung stehen.
Ach, verstehe.
0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer vom Plumun, vom heutigen Chaosradio, Teil 128. Angerufen hat René aus Löwenberg. Hallo René, guten Abend.
Hallo.
Du hast jetzt sehr lange warten müssen. Ich hoffe, du kannst das verschmerzen, weil du hast ja gehört, was hier hier los war.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall dafür, dass die Leute mehr überwacht werden sollten.
Aha, wieso das denn?
Weil immer noch zu viel passiert. Also mir ist es egal, ob ich bei Aral abwischt werde wie drei Bierkurve oder zwei Schachten Gippen oder fünf Liter Tanker. Ist doch egal. Jeder, der nichts zu verbergen hat, der hat auf jeden Fall gar keine Probleme. Und ich hör immer nur, dass die Leute damit ein Problem haben, dass sie überwacht werden. Warum denn?
Na ja, du hast doch schon mitbekommen, dass zum Beispiel der Anrufer vorhin halt nicht mehr genau weiß, ob er noch irgendwie mit jemandem telefonieren kann, weil er einfach nicht weiß, wem zuhört. Wir hatten hier gerade von Martin gehört, dass offensichtlich die Polizei tatsächlich ein bisschen geschlafen hat, hineinbeobachtet hat. Möchtest du das?
Na, also es ist mir doch egal, weil ich begehe ja keine Straftate, wenn ich telefoniere oder im Internet bin. Es ist mir doch selber egal.
Im Endeffekt ist das, was René jetzt sagt, durchaus ein gewichtiges Argument. Jeder muss für sich selber entscheiden, wie er mit der ganzen Geschichte umgeht und wie man dazu steht. Und wenn du sagst, mir ist egal, dann ist das eine vollkommen freie Entscheidung von dir, die du im Zweifelsfall vor dir selber rechtfertigen musst.
Du ist schon richtig, aber ich spreche hier den Gag mal für viele, weil... Warum, warum, ist doch egal, ob jeder weiß, dass ich einen Dreißigstab bei Shell kaufe oder ob ich hier fünf Kilo Schwatt bei allem ankaufe, ist doch egal.
Vielleicht, du hast ja die Geschichte mitbekommen von Martin, die hier erzählt wurde. Und jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz, könntest du dir vorstellen, dass dich so was treffen würde? Aber dann findest du trotzdem keine Unangenehme?
Nein, weil ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
Du sagst, sie könnten dein Haus ruhig durchsuchen und dir eine GPS-Wanze ans Telefon machen, dein Schlafzimmer abhören, dein Telefon abhören, deine E-Mails lesen und du hättest da kein Unangenehmes Gefühl.
Nein, überhaupt gar nicht, weil ich habe meinen Sex so wie jeder anderen hat oder auch nicht. Aber es ist egal.
René, ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich bin froh, dass du angerufen hast und auch diese andere Seite der Diskussion hier in diese Sendung reingetragen hast, denn um es normal zu sagen, die Entscheidung, wie man dazu steht, liegt eindeutig bei einem selber und wenn du das so siehst, dann... Genau, alles klar. Danke dir für deinen Anruf. Dir auch, tschüss. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sven aus Lichtenberg. Hallo Sven. Grüße dich. Was hältst du denn von der Sache, die René gerade erzählt hat, dass es einem egal ist? Also diese klassische... Ich hab ja nichts zu befürchten.
Also ich habe mir sehr oft und sehr lange darüber Gedanken gemacht. Ich habe dieses auch nachgeforscht und habe sehr bedenkliche Ergebnisse herausgefunden.
Was hast du nachgeforscht?
Na, wie zum Beispiel ein Verkäufer, den ich mal mir was gekauft habe, mich über Internet anschreiben kann und mir genau das anbietet, was ich genau brauche. Dann habe ich mir mal Gedanken gemacht, wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Es ist egal, was du benutzt, ob es deine EC-Karte ist, ob es irgendwelche Playback-Punkte sind, darüber werden Daten gespeichert.
Playback-Punkte gefällt mir übrigens auch sehr.
Ja, das ist zarkastisch, aber es ist wirklich schlimm. Einige Leute wissen nicht, was sie damit anrichten. Ob du dir hier eine Zeitung abonnierst, da hast du schon verloren. Weil sie wissen genau, was sind deine Interessen, was für Bücher liest du. Wenn du Bücher aus dem Internet holst, was für Bücher interessiert dich. Und in dem Moment kriegst du Post, in dem Moment kriegst du Information, du wirst eingeschätzt, du wirst eingeschätzt, was interessiert dich, für was willst du zu haben. Es ist doch schlimm zu wissen, dass man so kontrolliert wird.
Was nicht nur damit passiert, was du an Post bekommst und für was dich interessiert, was auch noch nicht angesprochen wurde, sind solche Geschichten, dass man ein Profil erstellt von der Gegend, in dem du wohnst. Wenn in deiner Straße zum Beispiel 20 Leute bei Quelle, Otto, wo auch immer, irgendwas bestellen und von den 20 Leuten bezahlen, 18 nicht pünktlich, dann kriegst du in deiner Straße ein Häkchen in dein Profil rein, in dem drin steht, René zahlt bitte per Vorkasse.
Das würde mich nicht stören. Was aber schlimm ist, ist, dass es Dealer gibt, die deine Informationen verkaufen, die dadurch noch Geld machen. Und das kann es nicht sein. Ich werde sozusagen protokolliert, auf diese Art und Weise, im Grunde genommen, ich weiß nicht, ob der Film Staatsfeind Nummer 1 bekannt ist. Man könnte sich dadurch nur schützen, indem man in einem Käfig leben würde, der komplett von der Außenwelt abgeschottet ist. Indem man keine EC-Karten benutzt, keine Handys, die per Vertrag laufen, sondern Prepaid-Karten. Das wäre aber auch schon anzapfbar, da Handys auf dem Markt schwarz kaufen sind, die zu präparieren sind. Das heißt, du kannst überall ausgetauscht werden.
Hör mal Luft, ganz kurz, bevor du mir da Hyperventilien umkippst. Die von dir eben konstruierte Situation, das wäre aber ein ganz schön langweiliges Leben, wenn man da in seiner kleinen Kiste wohnt und mit keinem telefoniert.
Das ist richtig. Ich sage mal so, wenn ich mir so meinen Vorgänger angehört habe, der mir angeblich erzählen möchte, er ist sauber. Also das ist ja wie, als wenn er mir erzählen würde, er hat in seinem Leben noch nie gelügt. Das wäre die größte Lüge seines Lebens. Also kein Mensch ist perfekt, kein Mensch macht keine Fehler. Und es gibt Fehler, die man macht und die man angeblich, am liebsten nicht gerne an die Großglocke gehangen haben möchte. Und wenn ich mir so überlege und mir so angehört habe in der Sendung, ich höre eure Sendung übrigens jedes Mal, es gibt keine Sendung, die ich nicht gehört habe.
Oh, danke.
Es ist absolut Hammer, ihr habt Themen, da bin ich...
Okay, pass auf, da uns die Zeit wegläuft, lass uns mal diese, wir schenken uns gegenseitig Blumen und backen uns einen Kuchengeschicht in eine andere Mama.
Ja, die haben wir ja auch gehabt. Ein Kollege von mir, den haben sie hops genommen, auf gut Deutsch. Ja, und warum? Weil er für einen Kollegen eine CD kopiert hat und sozusagen der Kollege wurde überprüft und wurde, wie der Kollege hier im Studio, beschattet. Und dadurch, dass er ja Kontakt mit ihm hatte, war er genauso verdächtig wie alle anderen. Und das kann es nicht sein, dass man, weil man eine Kleinigkeit kopiert hat, gleich als Straftäter betitelt wird. Da gibt es andere Sachen, ja, wie Kinderschänder oder so, um die sie sich kümmern sollten. So eine Leute sollten sie abhören, so eine Leute sollten sie überprüfen. Den Leuten gehören eigentlich die Pfoten abgehackt. Ja, wenn ich mir gucke, dass Kinder, Pädophile, die aus dem Internetdaten ziehen, vier Jahre kriegen und Leute, die Kinder missbrauchen, beiher oder ein...
Sven, pass auf, wir machen jetzt genau wieder Folgendes, was wir eben schon mal gemacht haben, hol mal Luft. Also für deine Meinung vielen Dank, aber ich denke, wir sollten auch das, was René eben gesagt hat, der sagte, mir ist es doch egal, können sie machen, so eine Meinung muss man respektieren. Wenn jemand sagt, mir ist es egal, ich hab mir nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen, sollen sie doch kommen, dann muss man sagen, okay, wenn du so dazu stehst, bitteschön, es ist deine freie Entscheidung.
Aber unterstützt in ihrer Meinung, kann es nicht sein. Der kleine Bürger hat genauso das Recht, sich zu wehren. Und wenn nur eine Stimme sagt, nein, ich möchte das nicht, dann haben sie das zu akzeptieren.
Punkt, warte mal, haben sie das zu akzeptieren? Punkt, weil wir eigentlich nur noch 5 Minuten Zeit haben, weil Martin Petersdorf steht vor der Tür und die Telefonleistung Eick fliegt mir um die Ohren.
Alles klar, dann möchte ich nur noch letzten Satz sagen, Shit Happens, auf gut Deutsch.
Ich brauche jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr sagen, dass ihr noch anrufen könnt, weil wir schaffen sowieso eigentlich schaffen wir nur noch einen Anrufer. Alle anderen möchte ich bitten, also A, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt weiter über diese Sendung diskutieren, entweder im Fritzboard, auf fritz.de oder eure Fragen direkt stellen an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und das letzte Thema, was wir heute aufmachen, dann ist dann auf jeden Fall auch nochmal Sönke bei uns, nämlich unser Anwalt, kommt von Markus aus Leipzig.
Guten Abend.
Grüße dich.
Soll ich gleich anfangen? Also ich rufe an, weil ich noch was beisteuern wollte, und zwar, wir hatten drüber gesprochen, 129A, Bildung einer terroristischen Vereinigung, Sprengstoffanschläge, Mord und Totschläge und so weiter, aber da gibt es auch noch andere Themen. Seit zwei Monaten gibt es die sogenannten Hackerparagrafen, 202A bis C und 303A bis B im Strafgesetzbuch, die halt Computersabortage, Datenveränderungen, Ausspielung von Daten unter Strafe stellen, und der 303B, Computersabortage und auch die Folgeparagrafen werden eben auch in 129A mitgenannt. Also sprich, da gibt es halt auch für die Behörden ganz neue Möglichkeiten, terroristische Vereinigungen sich bilden zu lassen, sage ich mal. Denn was man ja auch sagen muss ist, der 129A noch nie dazu geführt, dass jemand verurteilt worden ist, meines Wissens nach, sondern das enthalten seine Ermittlungsparagrafen.
Das ist jetzt sehr, sehr viel internes Fachchinesisch.
Also de facto, worum es da geht, ist das mit der Verschärfung der Computerkriminalitätsparagrafen ist de facto Hacking auch, also beziehungsweise Hacking im negativen Fall, also Angriff auf Computer und Computersabortage, zu einer sogenannten Katalogstraftat geworden. Das heißt also, wenn man sich dazu verabredet, dieses zu tun, dann kann man auch als terroristische Vereinigung betrachtet werden mit irgendwie all den Folgen, die wir heute hier schon ausführlich erläutert bekommen haben. Ja, also ist halt wieder mal eine weitere Verschärfung der Sachlage.
Der CCC ist damals quasi direkt betroffen, denn wir sind natürlich eine Vereinigung, die durch den Paragrafen in gewisser Weise bedroht wird. Und auch einige von den deutschen IT-Security-Firmen haben sich da doch sehr entsetzt gezeigt. Und es gibt auch schon Firmen, die ihr Geschäft ins Ausland verlagert haben, weil sie unter diesen Umständen hier auch nicht mehr arbeiten wollen.
Also danke nochmal für den Hinweis.
Welche Resonanzen gibt es da sozusagen von der Gesetzgeberseite auf diese ganzen kritischen Anmerkungen?
Also die Gesetzgeberseite ist, was jetzt die Abgeordneten betrifft, ist klar anzusehen, dass es sich dabei um Internet-Ausdrucke handelt. Es sind Leute, die ihre Computer nicht selber bedienen. Die haben ein explizites Verständnis vom Internet und von technischen Zusammenhängen, was sie aus Spielfilmen haben. Das merkt man auch immer wieder an Details. Die Beratungs-Assistenz ist extrem hoch. Da wird in der Regel nicht zur Kenntnis genommen, wenn alle Experten sagen, bitte macht das nicht so, das führt in die Katastrophe. Dann machen sie es erst recht so. Das sind unsere Erfahrungen aus der Lobbyarbeit, was diese Hacker-Paragraphen-Geschichte betrifft. Wir waren maßlos frustriert, wie stark da die Realitätszahne ist.
Man muss natürlich sehen, dass dieser Paragraph 202c seinen normalen Weg durch den Gesetzgebungsprozess genommen hat. Entsprechend gab es auch Anhörungen, etwa im Rechtsausschuss. Der CCC hat da Stellung genommen. Aber nicht nur wir, sondern auch die Wirtschaft hat Stellung genommen. Die Juristen haben Stellung genommen und die entsprechenden Verbände. Es gab eigentlich keine guten Gründe dafür. Dennoch hat eine große Mehrheit im Parlament dafür die Hand gehoben. Obwohl sich die Sachverständigen im Rechtsausschuss die Finger wundeschrieben haben und sich da auch eingefunden haben und ihre Sachverständigen Meinung da kundgetan haben. Es hat trotzdem nichts genutzt. Sie haben die Hand gehoben.
Warte mal, erstmal müssen wir sagen Danke, Markus. Und einen schönen Abend nach Leipzig. Bevor wir auf diese Veranstaltung hinweisen, würde ich gerne noch mal zwei grundsätzliche Fragen klären wollen, die in dieser Sendung ganz oft vorgekommen sind, aber die immer wieder auftauchen. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass Überwachung durch die Sicherheitsbehörden in diesem Staat nicht nur eine angedachte Geschichte ist, sondern sehr real passiert. Wir haben viele Geschichten gehört, die ihr erlebt habt. Frage Nummer eins, wie kriege ich mit, dass so etwas läuft, gegenüber mich, über mich mit mir?
Nicht?
Gar nicht.
Was ist denn denn, Sie wollen es?
Frage Nummer zwei, was kann ich machen?
Naja, wenn man es halt mitkriegt, irgendwie zum Anwalt gehen. Das ist wahrscheinlich der einzige Rat, den man da irgendwie gut geben kann.
Ja, ich denke der Fall von Martin ist fast schon der Beleg dafür, dass man eigentlich vernünftig nichts machen kann. So blöde wie es kommen kann, können wir als Bürgerinnen und Bürger gar nicht vorausdenken. Und auch, das betrifft ja euch vom CCC, gerade auch seit der 309b im 129a drin ist. Also seit ein Hackerverein, eine terroristische Vereinigung sein können. Ihr könnt so viel Hackerethik haben, wie ihr wollt. Ihr wisst nicht, wie die Behörden das bewerten. Und ihr könnt auch heute nicht in die Herzen der Richter schauen, die eines Tages darüber entscheiden müssen. Ihr steht hier mit einem Bein, ich will nicht sagen im Gefängnis, aber mit einem Bein doch in einem Problem. Und könnt selber mit euch abmachen, wollt eure Freiheit gebrauchen, wollt ihr hacken, wollt ihr programmieren, wollt ihr eure Hacker-Agek pflegen oder wollt ihr sozusagen im Voraus einen Gehorsamen euch einen Kopf drüber machen, was gönnt ein Staatsanwalt davon haben?
Ja gut, also die Antwort ist halt ganz klar, wir stecken halt nicht den Kopf in den Sand. Weil wir haben ernsthaft erwogen, ob Auswahl eine Option wäre. Und wir haben uns dafür entschieden, doch lieber hierzu bleiben und zu kämpfen.
Also da muss man vielleicht noch mal eine Sache anmerken, weil ja vorhin auch noch mal die Sprache darauf kam, dass etwa die Benutzung von Privacy Enhancing Tools, also etwa Verschlüsselung oder dergleichen, einen besonders verdächtig macht. Ich würde halt ungern diese Message stehen lassen. Uns geht es eigentlich darum zu sagen, wenn viel mehr Leute ihre Privatsphäre mit Verschlüsselung nutzen würden und eben nicht alle E-Mails und Verschlüsselung und alle Chats und vielleicht auch mehr Anonymisierungssoftware benutzen würden, dann würde man da auch nicht so auffallen. Also wir hoffen halt nicht, dass gerade solche Berichte, wie sie Martin hier abgeliefert haben, dazu führen, dass du sagen würdest, ich benutze lieber gar keine Verschlüsselung, dann könnt ihr gerne ins Verhandlungsraster fahren. Das ist gerade nicht die Message, die wir bringen wollen, sondern wir wollen sagen, benutzt diese Tools.
Wir haben noch, jetzt kam das Ding mit dem Veranstaltungshinweis und dann würde ich gerne noch ein Schlusswort sagen. Ja genau, wir haben ja heute schon ein paar Sachen sprechen können, aber wir haben jetzt für den kommenden Sonntag um 11 Uhr, also eine Martinä in der Volksbühne am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz in Berlin eine große Veranstaltung geplant, wo unter anderem über diesen Fall hier auch berichtet wird, aber wo auch noch mal die Möglichkeit besteht, zum 129a noch mal Fragen zu stellen. Es wird einen anderen Fall geben, wo noch jemand mal beschreibt, dem jetzt schon mehrfach passiert ist mit dem 129a, wie es ihm ergangen ist. Und es wird noch mal einen Bericht dazu geben, warum es notwendig ist, weiter sich auch zu organisieren, sich politisch zu wehren und nicht nur Abgeordnete anzuschreiben oder mit denen zu telefonieren, sondern auch selber was auf die Beine zu stellen. Kostas Eintritt? Muss man ja nur mal ganz kurz fragen. Also, das war's Chaosradio Teil 128 zum Thema Überwachung ganz real. Vielen Dank für eure ganzen Anrufe. Ich kann nicht lesen, was du mir da hingeschrieben hast.
Na, wir wollten noch auf die Sendung trackbacken, die Show mit Spereblick.
Ich wollte erst mal sagen, vielen Dank für eure Anrufe. Wenn man das zusammenfassen kann, was heute passiert ist, sind die Reaktionen auf diese ganzen Geschichten und Erlebnisse. Das macht mir Angst und ich weiß nicht, wie ich damit umgehen kann. Bis hin zu, ist mir doch egal, sollen sie doch einfach kommen. Ich denke, was wir alle mitnehmen können, ist, dass es wichtig ist, darüber einfach mal zu reden, sich darüber zu informieren und im Zweifelsfall anderen Leuten zu sagen, ich habe da ein komisches Gefühl, um einfach sich irgendwo mitzuteilen, um das weiter in die Welt zu tragen. Weiterhin möchte ich hinweisen, dass es auf Fritz nicht nur das Chaosradio gibt, sondern auch eine schöne Sendung namens trackback. Das läuft jeden Samstag von 18 Uhr bis 20 Uhr. Auf trackback geht es an diesem Samstag um Biometrie und um den neu einzuführenden E-Pass. Damit vielen Dank an den Chaos Computer Club, an Konstanze und an Frank. Vielen Dank an Martin für deine Geschichte. Vielen Dank an Sönke und vielen Dank an Volker. Euch einen schönen Abend. Wir gehen jetzt weiter mit Martin Petersdorf im Night Flight. Ich bin schon mal da.